I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。
Hi there. Hey. We are about to start down a very exciting road. We are moving on. Part one. And then. Part two. It's a big episode. It really is. And we'll tell you why.
大家好。嘿。我们将要踏上一段非常激动人心的旅程。我们要向前看了。第一部分。然后。第二部分。这是一集大制作。确实如此。我们会告诉你为什么。
Should we get into it? We better. We have a lot to cover. It is season nine, episode 16, written by Graham Wagner and directed by Jon Favreau. Yeah. Here's your summary. An already grieving Andy flips out when he learns about Aaron and Pete's new relationship.
我们该切入正题了吗？最好是这样。我们要聊的内容很多。这是第九季第十六集，由格雷姆·瓦格纳编剧，乔恩·费儒导演。对。这是你的剧情梗概。原本就处于悲伤之中的安迪在得知亚伦和皮特的新恋情后彻底崩溃了。
Pam has a job interview in Philly, and the boss's personality is eerily familiar. Meanwhile, Dwight enlists Angela for help bathing his elderly ailing aunt. You know, I know Dwight says that Aunt Shirley is ailing, but she looked pretty sturdy. Very hearty. Very hearty to me.
帕姆在费城有一个工作面试，而老板的个性有着诡异的熟悉感。与此同时，德怀特拉拢安吉拉帮忙给他年迈生病的阿姨洗澡。你知道，我知道德怀特说阿姨雪莉病了，但她看起来挺健壮的。非常硬朗。在我看来非常硬朗。
Certainly her personality. Uh-huh. Yes. All right, fast fact number one, John Favreau, as our director, you guys know John Favreau, he is a prolific actor, writer, and director. He wrote and starred in the movie Swingers, which is where I was introduced to him. Same.
她的个性肯定也是。嗯哼。是的。好的，趣事一号，乔恩·费儒，作为我们的导演，你们都知道乔恩·费儒，他是一位多产的演员、编剧和导演。他编剧并主演了电影《求爱俗辣》，这也是我认识他的地方。我也是。
Oh my gosh. Our whole generation was. You just wanted to be in that movie. You were like, oh, I've been there and I've done that, but it didn't look half as cool. I know. They go to this swing club called The Derby, which was a real place in Los Angeles. And you know, I started going to The Derby
噢天哪。我们整代人都是。你当时就只想加入那部电影。你会想，哦，我到过那里，我也做过那些事，但它看起来可没有一半那么酷。我知道。他们去了一个叫“德比”的摇滚舞俱乐部，那是洛杉矶的一个真实地方。你知道的，我开始去“德比”
after I saw that movie. I'd never been. So many people did. I know. And I would swing dance, and it was so fun. Oh my gosh. I think it closed down, The Derby. Yeah.
是在我看了那部电影之后。我以前从没去过。很多人都去了。我知道。而且我会去跳摇滚舞，真的很有趣。噢天哪。我想它已经关门了，“德比”。是的。
I know. Anyway, Jon Favreau has also directed Iron Man, Iron Man 2, The Jungle Book, and he directed and starred in one of my personal favorite movies that I've watched multiple times, Chef. Have you seen this movie, Chef? No. Oh my God. He plays a chef, and he's at a fancy restaurant, and he has a big meltdown. And so his only option is to then buy a food truck and sell food out of the food truck.
我知道。不管怎样，乔恩·费儒还导演了《钢铁侠》、《钢铁侠2》、《奇幻森林》，他还导演并主演了我个人最喜欢且看过好几遍的电影之一《落魄大厨》。你看过这部电影吗，《落魄大厨》？没有。噢天哪。他扮演一个厨师，他在一家高级餐厅工作，然后情绪彻底崩溃了。所以他唯一的选择就是买辆餐车，通过餐车卖食物。
This kind of sounds like that show, The Bear. Chef at a fancy place, oh no, like it has to go to a smaller place to cook. I'm doing a horrible summary of it. Yeah, I don't watch The Bear. So I don't know, but I watch Chef multiple times. And I did not know this fact.
这听起来有点像那部剧，《熊家餐馆》。高级餐厅的厨师，哦不，就像不得不去一个较小的地方做饭。我对它的概括真是糟透了。对，我不看《熊家餐馆》。所以我不知道，但我看了好几遍《落魄大厨》。而且我不知道这个事实。
Did you know that he directed the Will Ferrell Christmas movie Elf? Really? John Favreau directed Elf. God, I love Elf. Yeah. I've seen that movie many times. Well, I know another thing you've seen
你知道他导演了威尔·法瑞尔的圣诞电影《圣诞精灵》吗？真的吗？乔恩·费儒导演了《圣诞精灵》。天哪，我喜欢《圣诞精灵》。是的。那部电影我看过很多遍。好吧，我知道你还看过他的另一部作品，
that he is like the executive producer creator of, which is The Mandalorian. You betcha. Oh my gosh, The Mandalorian. You know, one of the coolest things for y'all that watch it, don't you just love like the drawings of the scenes are so beautiful, how they do that in the credits? I wouldn't know. Oh, Jenna. Okay. All right. And we've got a couple of really fun
他是那种执行制片人和创作者的身份，也就是《曼达洛人》。当然啦。噢天哪，《曼达洛人》。你知道的，对你们这些看剧的人来说最酷的事情之一，难道你不觉得那些场景的素描非常漂亮吗，他们在片尾字幕里是怎么做到的？我可不知道。哦，珍娜。好吧。好吧。我们还有一些非常有趣的
crossover connections. He was in the movie The Replacements with David Denman and Keanu Reeves. Yeah. Office Lady's favorite. And he has appeared on Monk. I have a crossover with John Favreau. You do. You have an acting crossover. You know, we talked a lot about what it was like to work with John during our interview with Jake Lacey, because this was very memorable for all of us. It really was. You know, we were all so excited to work with him because we were all fans of his work. And he's a real, like, actor's actor. He's a director that, like, he gets in the scene with you and helps you figure it out, and we love that. But he's also just really easy to talk to. I have such fond memories of hanging out with him when we were filming at Aunt Shirley's house. We had to wait for it to get dark.
跨界联系。他曾与大卫·丹曼和基努·里维斯一起出演电影《替补队员》。是的。办公室辣妈的最爱。而且他还在《神探阿蒙》中出现过。我和乔恩·费儒有个跨界联系。你有的。你们在表演上有过跨界。你知道，在我们采访杰克·莱西时，我们聊了很多关于和乔恩合作的感受，因为这对我们所有人都非常难忘。确实如此。你知道，我们所有人都对能与他合作感到非常兴奋，因为我们都是他作品的粉丝。而且他是一个真正的、那种“演员的演员”。他是一个会亲自和你一起进入场景并帮你理清思路的导演，我们非常喜欢这一点。而且他也很容易交流。当我们在雪莉阿姨的房子里拍摄时，我和他一起闲逛留下了非常美好的回忆。我们必须等待天黑。
We had a little bit of downtime between scenes because we did all of those scenes on one day. And it has to end with that scene on the front porch with Dwight and Angela, right? Yeah. So we're sitting on the back porch of this house and he and I just ended up talking about improv and our love of it and of being in the moment and then different improv shows we did. We did that geeky thing that improv actors do where they talk about bits they did but no one else can really get them because it happened in the moment.
在场景之间我们有一点空闲时间，因为我们把所有这些场景都在一天内拍完了。而且必须以德怀特和安吉拉在前廊的那个场景结束，对吧？是的。所以我们坐在那个房子的后廊上，他和我就开始聊即兴表演，以及我们对它的热爱，对当下这种状态的热爱，然后是我们做过的不同的即兴表演节目。我们做了即兴演员会做的那种极客的事情，他们会谈论他们做过的桥段，但其他人很难真正理解，因为那是在当下发生的。
You know, Angela, I loved hearing you talk about him because that was exactly my same experience of him. And I find that a lot of times you have a director that's either like really good with actors or maybe that's really good on the technical side. And John is one of those people who shines in both spaces. I asked Steve Burgess, how did we get him? How did we get John Favreau? Yeah. And Steve said, we went out to a lot of what he called
你知道，安吉拉，听到你谈论他我很高兴，因为这和我对他的体验完全一样。我发现很多时候你遇到的导演要么很擅长对付演员，要么就是在技术方面很强。而乔恩就是那种在两个领域都大放异彩的人。我问史蒂夫·伯吉斯，我们是怎么请到他的？我们是怎么请到乔恩·费儒的？是的。史蒂夫说，我们联系了许多他所说的“流浪导演”，我们也知道这些人都是《办公室》的粉丝。乔恩·费儒就是个粉丝，而且档期也合适。史蒂夫说他几乎是演艺圈最忙的人，现在依然如此。但史蒂夫·伯吉斯以前和他合作过，深知和他合作总是那么棒，这次也不例外。我知道我们的剧组非常喜欢乔恩，因为我一直在和戴夫·罗杰斯互发电子邮件，他说当克莱尔剪辑这一集时，后期制作中的每个人都非常喜欢乔恩。
journeyman directors, who we also knew to be fans of The Office. And John Favreau was a fan and the dates worked out. Steve said he's pretty much the busiest guy in showbiz and still is. But Steve Burgess had worked with him before and just knew that he is always great to work with, and that this was no exception. I know that our crew loved John because I was trading emails with Dave Rogers, who said that while Claire edited this episode, everyone in post-production loved John.
他们太高兴他能来剧组工作了。戴夫说他让乔恩·费儒在他的《求爱俗辣》剧本上签了名。戴夫真的是个电影迷，这太可爱了。我喜欢这样。我知道。戴夫说，整个后期制作组一起去电影院看了第一部《复仇者联盟》。所以乔恩能来到他们的区域让他们非常兴奋。我敢说他们一定都乐坏了。我们也都乐坏了。同样乐坏了。而且你知道，安吉拉，我们之前分享过，这一集《向前看》原本打算只拍一集。它本来不是上下两集的，但格雷q太喜欢乔恩交出的所有素材了，
They were so thrilled that he came to work on the show. Dave said he got John Favreau to sign his swingers script. Dave is such a fan of movie and film and that is so cute. I love that. I know. Dave said that all of post-production had gone to see the first Avengers together in the theater. So this was very exciting to have John in their area. I bet they were all so tickled. We were all so tickled. Also tickled. And you know, Angela, we've shared this before, but this episode of Moving On was originally supposed to be just one episode. It was not going to be a two-parter, but Greg loved everything
以至于他回到电视网要求将其改成两集，这样他就能用上所有的镜头了。好了。你们准备好听趣事二号了吗？是的，我准备好了。好吧，这一集里有两位了不起的客串明星。趣事二号讲的全是鲍勃·奥登科克饰演马克。我太喜欢这些场景了。我也是。
that John turned in so much that he went back to the network and asked them to make it two episodes so he could use all the footage. All right. Are you ready for Fast Fact Number Two? Yes, I am. Well, we have two amazing guest stars in this episode. Fast Fact Number Two is all about Bob Odenkirk as Mark. I enjoyed these scenes so much. Me too.
其实在我们来之前，我今天早上还重新看了一遍，因为我想学会他唱的那首歌。真的吗？对。他唱给帕姆听的那首？是的。好吧，继续。所以，你知道，在第九季中，
I actually rewatched them this morning before we came in because I wanted to learn the song he sings. You did? Yeah. That he sings to Pam? Yes. Okay, go on. So, you know, in season nine,
当我们大致在讨论帕姆最终试图在费城找工作这个故事情节时，格雷格认为如果她在费城面试的那家公司就像是一个平行的邓德·米弗林宇宙，那会非常有趣。所以就像吉姆在费城的生活和职业生涯带他去到所有全新的地方一样。是的，它看起来很时髦、光鲜亮丽，还有一个手足球桌和豪华会议室。这看起来像是一种退步，对吧？是的。
when we were sort of discussing this storyline of Pam eventually trying to get a job in Philly, Greg thought it would be really funny if the office that she interviews at in Philly is like an alternate Dunder Mifflin universe. So like while Jim's life and career in Philly is like taking him to all new places. Yeah, it's like sleek and shiny and there's a foosball table and fancy conference room. This looks like a step back, right? Yes.
直接回到了她刚来邓德·米弗林的时候。这正是他所希望的。然后格雷格说，如果老板长得跟迈克尔·斯考特一模一样，那不是太棒了吗？所以工作是一样的，然后人们甚至有点倒退了。也就是在那时他说，我们应该让鲍勃·奥登科克来扮演那个角色。我知道我在播客的早期就讲过这个故事，
Right back to the beginning of her time at Dunder Mifflin. That is exactly what he was hoping for. And then Greg said, wouldn't it be amazing if the boss was exactly like Michael Scott? So the job is the same and then like the people are even sort of a step back. And that's when he was like, we should have Bob Odenkirk play that role. And I know I've told this story earlier on the podcast,
但你知道鲍勃·奥登科克是迈克尔·斯考特的最终候选人之一。他为迈克尔·斯考特的角色进行了试镜。因为他的妻子娜奥米·奥登科克是我的长期经纪人，她建议鲍勃和我一起为试镜做准备。主要是因为很多试镜内容都需要即兴发挥，而我没有这个背景，但鲍勃有。他非常慷慨地和我聚在一起，做了一些类似于迈克尔·斯考特和帕姆的即兴表演来做准备。噢天哪，我当时真是崇拜得不行。
but you know Bob Odenkirk was one of the finalists for Michael Scott. He tested for the role of Michael Scott. And because his wife, Naomi Odenkirk, is my longtime manager, she suggested that Bob and I prepare for our tests together. Mostly because a lot of the audition was going to be improvisation, and I don't have that background, but Bob does. And he very generously got together with me and did some sort of Michael Scott-Pam improv together to prepare. Oh my God, I was so starstruck.
但这就是鲍勃饰演平行迈克尔·斯考特这个想法的来源，在格雷格的脑海里。好吧，格雷格最聪明的地方也在于，从来没有什么东西会被浪费。就像，他一看到什么或者想到什么，就会把它存在大脑里，然后在几年后把它拿出来。没错。好吧，你知道的，我们当时非常兴奋，因为鲍勃来到了录音室和我们聊了他在《办公室》里的经历。
But that's where the idea of Bob playing alternate Michael Scott came from, in Greg's mind. Well, that's the brilliant thing about Greg, too, is that nothing is ever wasted. Like, the minute he sees something or thinks about it, he will just file that away in his brain and years later bring it back. That's right. Well, you know, we were pretty excited because Bob came in the studio to talk with us about his time on The Office.
是的，他来了。那是一次非常有趣的采访。我们要等到剖析完《向前看》上下两集之后才播出它，但大家都知道这期节目就要来了。是的，鲍勃来到了录音室。好的，接下来是趣事三，另一位大牌客串明星，玛丽·吉利斯饰演雪莉阿姨。这位女士真是一位才华横溢的角色演员。
Yes, he did. It was such a fun interview. We're going to wait to air it until after we break down moving on, part one and part two, but everybody just know that is coming up. Yes, Bob in the studio. Okay, moving on to Fast Fact 3, another big guest star, Mary Gillis as Aunt Shirley. This woman is such a brilliant character actress.
她简直太棒了。太棒了。说起那种能镇得住场面的人。哦，对，对。我是说，我从她在《午夜狂奔》中的角色记住了她，因为即使是在小角色中，她也是那种能大放异彩的人。你们可能还记得她。
She was just fantastic. Fantastic. Talk about someone who could command a room. Oh, yeah, yeah. I mean, I remember her from her role in Midnight Run because even in like just small roles, she's one of those people who pop. You guys might remember her.
她在《欢乐合唱团》中常驻出演了哈格伯格太太。她演过大量的电视剧。我的另一个最爱是她出演了《人人都爱雷蒙德》中名为“玛丽的雕塑”的那一集。你知道那一集吗？我以前不知道，但现在我很好奇。玛丽去上雕塑课，在这门大课结束时，他们揭幕了她的雕塑，
She had a recurring role on Glee as Mrs. Hagberg. She's done a ton of television. Another one of my favorites is that she is on the Everybody Loves Raymond episode called Marie's Sculpture. Do you know that one? I've known, but now I'm curious. Marie takes a sculpture class and at the end of this big class, they like unveil her sculpture
结果那个雕塑看起来非常像一个巨大的阴道。而且没有人知道该怎么夸奖它。非常搞笑。我们收到了来自康涅狄格州西黑文的艾莉·J.的一个粉丝提问，她问：“玛丽·吉利斯一直是我在《办公室》中最喜欢的客串明星之一。她是怎么得到这个角色的？”好吧，我这里有一些劲爆的幕后八卦。你知道玛丽·吉利斯并不是第一个雪莉阿姨吗？不，她不是。谁是第一个雪莉阿姨？好吧。这个故事有很多曲折。哦。所以我们开始吧。好的。
and it is just, it very much looks like a giant vagina. And nobody knows how to compliment it. It's very funny. We got a fan question from Alison J. in West Haven, Connecticut, who asked, Mary Gillis has always been one of my favorite guest stars on The Office. How did she get her role? Well, I've got some hot trivia on this. Did you know that Mary Gillis was not the first Aunt Shirley? No, she wasn't. Who was the first Aunt Shirley? Okay. The story has a lot of twists and turns. Oh. So here we go. Okay.
所以在这个第九季期间，全国广播公司（NBC）正在探索拍摄一部以雷恩·威尔逊为主演的《办公室》衍生剧的想法。我知道这个。叫《农场》。是的。保罗·利伯斯坦是运作人，他们拍了一集。
So during this season nine, NBC was exploring the idea of an office spinoff starring Rainn Wilson. This I know. Called The Farm. Yeah. Paul Lieberstein was the show runner and they shot an episode.
那一集的剧情是德怀特的雪莉阿姨去世了，留给他了什么，我猜是农场？是的。是的。好吧，他们拍了。远在我们拍这一集之前。他们在今年早些时候拍的，他们选了一个女演员来演雪莉阿姨。拍完之后，当他们发现这部剧不会继续拍下去时，
And the plot of that episode is that Dwight's Aunt Shirley has passed away and has left him, I guess, the farm? Yeah. Yeah. Well, they shot it. Long before we shot this episode. They shot it earlier in the year, and they cast a woman as Aunt Shirley. After it was finished, and they found out that the show wasn't going to go forward,
他们决定把《农场》拍成《办公室》的一集。所以他们在写了《农场》之后写了《向前看》，以此作为《农场》的前传，来解释雪莉阿姨是谁。没错。这个雪莉阿姨的角色现在成了一个大角色。所以他们出去选了玛丽·埃利斯，然后他们不得不回去重新拍摄《农场》里的场景，让玛丽·吉利斯来演雪莉阿姨。我解释清楚了吗？你真的解释得很清楚。而且我认为这也解释了一点，如果你像我们现在这样按顺序重看这部剧，而且我们已经看过了《农场》。是的。我记得当时看的时候就在想，为什么安吉拉没有被邀请去参加葬礼？我知道！
they decided to make the farm an office episode. So they wrote moving on after they wrote the farm as a way to precede the farm to explain who Aunt Shirley is. Exactly. This character of Aunt Shirley was now like a big character. So they went out and they cast Mary Ellis and then they had to go back and reshoot the scenes in the farm with Mary Gillis as Aunt Shirley. Did I explain that okay? You really did. And I think it also explains something if you rewatch the show in order like we're doing now and we have watched the farm. Yeah. I remember watching it and thinking, why wasn't Angela invited to the funeral? I know!
她给这个女人洗过澡，给她做过饭，还陪了她整整一天。她肯定会想去参加葬礼的。雪莉阿姨的。雪莉阿姨的。但我们在几个月前就已经拍完《农场》了。是的。啊哈。
She bathed this woman and made her dinner and spent a whole day with her. Surely she would want to attend the funeral. Of Aunt Shirley. Of Aunt Shirley. But we had filmed the farm months before this. Yes. Aha.
是的，我想当他们在补拍新的雪莉阿姨的镜头时，他们应该把安吉拉加进去。去参加葬礼。是的。好吧，安吉拉，我们有好多粉丝关于你和雪莉阿姨对手戏的问题要问你。我把它们留到我们讲到那一集时再问。
Yeah, I think when they were doing their reshoots of the new Aunt Shirley, they should have added Angela there. To the funeral. Yes. Well, Angela, we have so many fan questions for you about your scenes with Aunt Shirley. I will save them until we get to them.
这就是我所有的趣事了。好吧，我觉得这些趣事真是棒极了。我只有两条通告单的小花絮要告诉你。哦。还有一些我后面会穿插着讲。我喜欢小花絮。你喜欢小花絮。这里有一些本期节目的通告单小花絮送给你。拍摄这一集的第一天是2013年1月14日。
That's all I got for Fast Facts. Well, I thought those were just fantastic. I have just two call sheet tidbits for you. Oh. And more that I'll sprinkle in later. I love a sprinkle. You love a sprinkle. Here's some Toppa Show call sheet tidbits for you. Day one of filming this episode was on January 14th, 2013.
我知道你们喜欢天气预报。那天是晴天，最高气温58华氏度，最低气温37华氏度。哦，那有点冷。尤其是呆在雪莉阿姨家外面的时候。是的。对我们演员阵容来说那是忙碌的一周。我们接待了好几拨访客，包括这周三来的电视评论家协会。是的，关于这个我后面有一个大新闻。哦，我们还有一次剧本围读。在这周的星期五，一个全国广播公司的EPK摄制组在片场拍摄B卷素材以及演员和导演采访。
I know you guys love a weather report. It was sunny with a high of 58 degrees and the low was 37. Ooh, that's kind of chilly. Especially out at Aunt Shirley's. Yeah. And it was a busy week for us as a cast. We had multiple visitors, including on Wednesday of this week, the Television Critics Association. Yes, and I have a big story about that for later. Oh, we also had a table read. And on the Friday of this week, an NBC EPK crew was on set doing B-roll and cast and director interviews.
我到处寻找他们对乔恩·费儒的采访，但就是找不到。哪里都找不到。我今天真的很想播放一些那样的音频片段。好吧，全国广播公司收听这个节目的某个人，如果你有存档素材，联系我们吧。我们有很多想要的东西。我们确实有。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下？当我们回来时，我们将开始剖析
And I looked everywhere for their interviews with Jon Favreau and I couldn't find them. Anywhere. I really wanted to be able to play some of those audio clips today. Well, someone at NBC listening to this that has archive footage, hit us up. We have a lot that we want. We do. All right, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we will start breaking down
这一集，还有一个我非常喜欢的冷开场。它把我逗乐了。我看了好几遍。我太喜欢埃德这一集里的表现了。我也真的很喜欢。他真的是放开演了。好吧，我们马上回来。好吧，这一集从安迪在会议室被大卫·华尔士痛骂开始。
this episode with a cold open that I really enjoyed. It tickled me. I watched it several times. I just love Ed in this episode. I really did too. He really goes for it. All right, we'll be back in just a second. Well, the episode starts with Andy getting yelled at by David Wallace in the conference room.
我们有点那种偷拍的镜头，你知道的，就是我们从办公区往里看的视角。大卫对安吉拉气急败坏。他对他说，你对我说谎了。你假装在这个办公室待了三个月，但其实你跑去你的船上了。安吉拉说，等等，我从来没说过谎。大卫说，哦，真的吗？然后他开始像这样翻看收据，对吧？正如孩子们所说的那样，他读了一封邮件，嘿，大卫，宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿一切都好。然后他说，奥斯卡向你问好。接着大卫说，拜托。
We kind of have that spy shot, you know, where we're looking from the bullpen in. David is furious with Andy. He says to him, you lied to me. You pretended to be in this office for three months, but you were off on your boat. And Andy's like, wait, I never lied. And he goes, oh, really? And then he starts like pulling up receipts, right? As the kids say, he reads an email, hey, David, all is good in Scranton, PA. And then he says, Oscar says hi. And then David's like, come on.
安吉拉说，什么？奥斯卡每天都问好。他总是问好。安吉拉接着说，你知道吗？你是个骗子，大卫。他读了一封邮件说，嘿，安吉拉，一切都好。一直想去那儿看看，但我妻子生病了。然后大卫说，好吧，到底是哪个？
And Andy's like, what? Oscar says hi every day. He always says hi. And Andy goes, you know what? You're a liar, David. And he reads an email that says, hey Andy, all's well. Been meaning to make it down there, but my wife's sick. And he goes, well, what is it?
是一切都好还是你妻子生病了？抓包。大卫说，我妻子？然后你就觉得，好吧。安吉拉说，撤退，撤退。他说，听着，我最近真的过得很艰难，你知道吗？亚伦把我甩了，而且我在船上时经历的那些“顿悟”时刻我什么也记不起来了。我真的很想念我的胡子。安吉拉说，你知道吗？我不会开除你的。就冲你，我才买下了这家公司。但我们现在扯平了。是的。好吧，在整个这段交流中，镜头不断切回到办公区，
Is all well or is your wife sick? Busted. And David's like, my wife? And then you're like, okay. Andy's like, retreat, retreat. And he said, look, things have just been really tough for me, you know? Aaron dumped me and I can't remember any of the aha moments I had on the boat. And I really missed my beard. And Andy's like, you know what? I'm not going to fire you. Just because of you, I own the company. But we're even now. Yeah. Well, during this whole exchange, you kind of keep cutting back to the bullpen to
捕捉每个人的反应。我想让大家知道那不是剧本写好的。那全都是乔恩·费儒的功劳。我只记得他非常清楚地关心我们每个人作为角色对这件事的反应。我真的觉得太棒了。在场景结束时，安吉拉背诵了一首J.B.乔维的诗。是的。我喜欢他那种“那是给你的”的态度。就像，这是他送出的礼物。我知道。我们收到了来自纽约州罗切斯特市的杰茜卡·N.的一个粉丝提问，
get everybody's reactions. And I want people to know that that was not scripted. That was all Jon Favreau. I just remember him so clearly caring about each of us reacting to this as our characters. I just thought it was great. At the end of the scene, Andy recites a poem by J.B. Jovi. Yeah. I love that he's like, that's for you. Like, it's his gift to give. I know. We had a fan question from Jessica N. in Rochester, New York,
她想知道，仅仅背诵一首歌的歌词还要付版权费吗？史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，只要埃德在说话时完全没有向旋律靠拢，我们就可以这样做，而不必为此付钱。真的吗？嗯-hmm。所以你一旦把它弄成曲调，你就得付钱。没错。
who wanted to know, does reciting just the words of a song still cost money? Steve Burgess said that as long as Ed just spoke the words without any nod at all to the melody, we could do that and not have to pay for it. Really? Mm-hmm. So the minute you make it a tune, you gotta pay it. That's right.
哦，哇。关于这个场景我还有一件事要说。我绝对喜欢安吉拉的外套和领带。哦。我真的很喜欢。那件外套是这种蓝色的，上面有那种非常淡、很大的类似棋盘格的细条纹。
Oh, wow. I have one other thing to say about this scene. I absolutely loved Andy's jacket and tie. Oh. I really did. The jacket is like this blue color and it has like this very light, large sort of checkerboard pinstripe.
然后领带是棕色的，带有白色波点。我觉得它真的很精神。我真的很喜欢这个搭配。不知道。记下了。好吧，你知道安吉拉说他想不起在船上的任何顿悟时刻的那一刻吗？嗯-hmm。我太喜欢了。我也是。
And then the tie is brown with white polka dots. And I thought it was real sharp. I really liked this combo. I don't know. Noted. Well, you know that moment where Andy says he can't recall any of his aha moments from the boat? Mm-hmm. I loved that. Me too. It got me so tickled.
我查了一下“顿悟时刻”。我只是对这个短语有些好奇，你知道的，它从何而来？天哪，我找到了最随机的东西。什么？谷歌没有让人失望，女士。你谷歌了“顿悟时刻”？是的，我查了。好吧，我急切地想知道结果。
And I looked up aha moment. I was just sort of curious about the phrase, you know, where does it come from? And oh my goodness, I found the most random thing. What? Google did not disappoint, lady. You Googled aha moment? Yes, I did. Okay, I'm dying to know the results.
好吧，有一个奥普拉·温弗瑞的视频，是由韦氏词典发布的，用来描述“顿悟时刻”。所以他们的描述包括了一个视觉参考。来自奥普拉。好的。你需要听一下。然后我要和你分享关于它的文章。
Okay, there is a video of Oprah Winfrey that was posted by the Merriam-Webster Dictionary describing an aha moment. So their description includes a visual reference. From Oprah. OK. You need to hear it. And then I'm going to share with you the article about it.
顿悟时刻。一个突然意识到、受到启发、产生洞察、认知或理解的时刻。我总是喜欢那些时刻，当我坐下来和某人交谈时，他们说了一些话，让我以一种完全不同的方式看待生活或某种情况。我说，啊哈，我懂了。电灯泡，叮，叮，叮，叮的时刻。
Aha moment. A moment of sudden realization, inspiration, insight, recognition, or comprehension. I always love those moments when I sit down to talk to somebody and they say something that makes me look at life or a situation in a completely different way. And I say, aha, I get it. Light bulb, bing, bing, bing, bing moment.
然后你手臂上的小汗毛都竖起来了。这就是顿悟时刻。我的意思是，这描述得太完美了。谢谢你，奥普拉。我知道。然后，好吧，这就是文章所说的，但我还觉得，我想这是我听过用一个词来形容的最华丽的方式，啊哈！我太喜欢了！然后我找到了这篇文章。显然，在2012年8月，韦氏词典发布了他们的年度词汇列表，游戏规则改变者（game changer）、发短信（sexting）、以及由奥普拉在她的脱口秀节目中普及的“顿悟时刻”（aha moment），因为她经常引用这些“顿悟
And the little hairs on your arms stand up. That is an aha moment. I mean, that is so perfectly described. Thank you, Oprah. I know. And then, okay, here's what the article said, but I also like, I think it's the fanciest way I've ever heard a word describe, aha! I love it! So then I found this article. Apparently, in August of 2012, Merriam-Webster released their annual list, game changer, sexting, and aha moment that was popularized by Oprah on her talk show because she would reference these aha
时刻”。噢天哪，你能想象创造一个后来被字典收录的短语吗？我知道。这就好像奥普拉做到了那件事。奥普拉真的让它流行了起来。后来被字典收录的短语吗？我知道。这就好像奥普拉做到了那件事。奥普拉真的让它流行了起来。她在2017年小哈里·康尼克的脱口秀节目中接受采访时这样说道，我引用一下：“你觉得你以前从未那样想过，但除非你已经知道了，否则你不可能有什么顿悟。”
moments quite a bit. Oh my gosh, could you imagine coining a phrase that then became recognized by the dictionary? I know. That's like Oprah did that. Oprah really made it popular. phrase that then became recognized by the dictionary? I know. That's like Oprah did that. Oprah really made it popular. She went on in an interview in 2017 on the Harry Connick Jr. talk show saying this, and I quote, You think you've never thought of it that way before, but you can't have an aha unless you already knew it.
所以“顿悟”是对你已经知道的事情的回忆，以一种能与你自己的真理产生共鸣的方式表达出来。所以“顿悟”不是某人在教你什么。顿悟是某人在帮你回忆起来。哦，所以它是从你内心深处被启发出来的。根据奥普拉的说法。这对我来说说得通，因为如果你只是在教我一个在我内心深处并不相关的冷知识，那就不是一个顿悟时刻，对吧？是的，所以这里有一件我觉得非常有趣的事。安吉拉在场景刚开始时说他忘记了他所有的顿悟时刻，但后来在厨房里他有了一个顿悟。当他看到那个写着“皮特”字的棕色纸袋时。他确实有了。
So the aha is the remembering of what you already knew, articulated in a way to resonate with your own truth. So the aha isn't somebody teaching you something. The aha is somebody helping you to remember. Oh, so it's the it's the bringing it up out of you. According to Oprah. That makes sense to me because if you're just teaching me a fact that isn't like sort of relevant inside of me, it's not an aha moment, right? Yeah, so here's something that I found very interesting. Andy says he forgets all of his aha moments at the very top of the scene, but then later in the kitchen he has an aha. When he sees the brown paper bag with the word Pete on it. He does.
那是他本来就知道的事。是的。然后被唤醒了。你知道这让我在想什么吗？我不知道为什么这会突然闯进我的脑海。我们正式巩固了“夹克衬衫”（Shacket）这个词吗？你知道的，那种衬衫式夹克。夹克衬衫，这几年在时尚界风靡一时。一种夹克衬衫。我从来没听过夹克衬衫。是的。它就像，它的分量是一件夹克，但它看起来像一件衬衫。这就是夹克衬衫。夹克的分量？是的。就像，它比一件衬衫重。这样你就可以穿上一件衬衫，感觉就像穿着一件夹克，因为它很耐磨。它很重，但它看起来像衬衫，它不看起来像夹克，它是夹克衬衫。我从没听过这个，我也没见过。
It's something he knew. Yes. That then was reminded of. Do you know what this is making me wonder? And I don't know why this is what has popped in my head. Have we officially cemented Shack-It? You know, the shirt jacket. The Shack-It, it's all the rage in the fashion
什么？什么，那是，什么？乔丹，卡茜，你们听过夹克衬衫吗？我绝对听过。谢谢你，乔丹。卡茜？我没有。谢谢你，卡茜。
world these last couple of years. A shacket. I have never heard of a shacket. Yes. It's like, it's the weight of a jacket, but it looks like a shirt. It's a shacket. The weight of a jacket? Yeah. Like, it's heavier than a shirt. This way you can put on a shirt that's like you're wearing a jacket because it's hardy. It's heavy, but it looks like a shirt, it doesn't look like a jacket, it's a shacket. I've never heard of this, I've never seen one.
哈哈哈哈！出现分歧了！乔丹，你和我正处于时尚界的边缘。显然。我们紧跟所有潮流。谁需要一件和夹克一样重的T恤？太荒谬了。这不是T恤，它就像你现在身上穿的衬衫。它是一件纽扣衬衫。
What? What, is that, what? Jordan, Cassie, have y'all heard of shackets? I definitely have. Thank you, Jordan. Cassie? I have not. Thank you, Cassie.
哦。但它和夹克一样重。它是夹克衬衫，哦，好吧，所以你不需要叠穿，但你确实会叠穿夹克衬衫，难道不是吗，乔丹，人们确实会叠穿它们，不管怎样，哦，是的，我有一些照片，如果你们想看看的话，你们想看一张夹克衬衫的照片吗？是的，我们会把它发到社交媒体上，供其他任何不了解夹克衬衫的人看。哦，天哪。好吧，乔丹，带着你的笔记本电脑进来吧。我戴上眼镜。
Ha ha ha ha! Divided! Jordan, you and I are just on the cusp of just the fashion world. Clearly. We're up with all the trends. Who needs a t-shirt that's as heavy as a jacket? That's ridiculous. It's not a t-shirt, it's like the shirt you're wearing now. It's a button-down shirt.
它基本上就是外面这层夹克。它看起来就像一件蓬松的法兰绒T恤。长袖的。是的。好吧，按照你的描述，我还以为那是一件T恤呢。哦，不。一件特别厚特别厚的T恤。
Oh. But it is as heavy as a jacket. It's a shacket oh okay so you don't have to layer but you do layer shack it's don't you Jordan people do layer them anyway oh yeah I have some pictures of you guys want to see would you like to see a picture of a shack it yes and we'll include them in social media for anyone else who isn't up on the shack it. Oh, Lord. All right, come on in with your laptop, Jordan. I'm putting on my glasses.
我在想，为什么会有人想穿一件特别厚特别厚的T恤？不。一件短袖的、厚厚有垫衬的T恤。那根本不存在。听起来你疯了。它现在还不存在，但谁知道呢？那会是一件“碎裂T恤”（shat-it）。那会是一件“碎裂T恤”。我们能查查它在韦氏词典里的意思吗？
It's basically just this outer jacket. It just looks like a puffy flannel t-shirt. Long sleeve. Yeah. Well, the way you described it, I thought it was a t-shirt. Oh, no. A really thick, thick t-shirt.
我们能模仿奥普拉的语气说“这就是我的碎裂时刻”吗？我想可以。好的。我们到哪了？我的天呐。我们到片头字幕了。哦，天哪。好吧，我们来聊聊这些片头字幕，因为我敢肯定粉丝来信一定会像雪花般飞来。
I thought, why does anyone want to wear a thick, thick t-shirt? No. A short sleeve, thick padded t-shirt. That's not a thing. You sounded crazy. It's not a thing yet, but who knows? That would be a shirt shat-it. That would be a shat-it. Can we do the Merriam-Webster meaning of it?
确实如此，因为它们被加长了。没错。我们在里面看到了工作巴士。我们看到了消防演习。我们看到了值日轮换表。我们看到了你们在复印机旁的那段精彩场景。哦，天哪。我为了这事联系了戴夫·罗杰斯。我说，戴夫，为什么是现在？我们快拍完这部剧了。也许这就是原因。我当时说，戴夫，为什么是现在？
And can we do Oprah voice like, and that is my shat it moment. I think so. Okay. Where are we? Holy moly. We are at the opening credits. Oh my Lord. Okay. Well, let's talk about these credits, because I bet there was a fan mail flurry.
我们快拍完这部剧了。为什么片头字幕这么长？把它全塞进去吧。戴夫说，直到目前为止，我们要么使用21秒的主标题序列，要么使用6秒的。你知道的，我们要么用长的，要么用短的。我们制作了一个超长的。
There was, because they are extended. Yep. We've got work bus in there. We've got fire drill. We've got chore wheel. We've got that amazing scene of you guys at the copier. Oh, my goodness. I reached out to Dave Rogers about this. I was like, Dave, why now? We're almost done with the show. Maybe that's this. I was like, Dave, why now?
这个有32秒长。我们需要它，因为当格雷格决定把这一集变成一个小时的时长时，我们的素材对于一个小时来说还不够多。我们不得不凑时长。我们确实这么做了。所以，是的，我们甚至在片头字幕里加上了一点额外的内容，以便我们能达到时长要求。这一集现在要开始了。安吉拉抵达公司，他试图向亚伦打招呼，但他却哭了起来，然后跑进了他的办公室。我知道我已经有很长一段时间没有评论前台的植物了，
We're almost done with the show. Why are the credits so long? Let's get it all in there. Dave said, up to this point, we would use either a 21 second main title sequence or a six second. You know, we either use a long ear or a quickie. We made an extra long one.
但在两分二十三秒的时候，那里有一盆看起来长势非常健康的常春藤。哦，那挺好的。我喜欢那个。好吧，接下来安吉拉开始在他的办公室里嚎啕大哭，镜头切到办公区，斯坦利说，我觉得大卫·华尔士应该把他开除了，让他从痛苦中解脱出来。
This one is 32 seconds long. We needed it because when Greg decided to turn this one episode into an hour-long episode, we didn't have quite enough footage for an hour long. We had to pad it. We did. So yeah, we padded even the credit sequence with a little extra so that we could hit our time. The episode is now going to start. Andy's arriving to work and he tries to greet Aaron, but he just starts to cry and he runs into his office. And I know I haven't commented on the plants at front reception in quite a while,
菲利丝说她无法忍受和悲伤的人待在一起，因为他们会让她感到悲伤。斯坦利说，嗯，我和……无法忍受和悲伤的人待在一起，因为他们会让人感到悲伤。斯坦利说，嗯，我对好色的人也是这样。太棒了。谢谢。谢谢你提供这个小八卦，斯坦利。来自加拿大的凯尔西·A.有一个关于菲利丝的问题。
but there is a very healthy thriving, what looks like to be an IV at two minutes and 23 seconds. Oh, that's nice. I like that. Well, next Andy is going to start wailing from his office and we cut to the bullpen and Stanley says, I think David Wallace should have fired him and put him out of his misery.
凯尔西注意到菲利丝在皮克斯电影《头脑特工队》中为“忧忧”这个角色配音，并想知道她在这一集里表现出悲伤时的样子——当她说“我不能和悲伤的人待在一起，他们让我感到悲伤”时——这就是她被选中在皮克斯电影中扮演那个角色的原因吗？因为她觉得当她说这句话时，听起来就像是忧忧。凯尔西，我也是这么想的。当我听到她说这句话时，这是我脑子里想到的第一件事。我也是。
And Phyllis says she can't stand to be around sad people because they make her sad. Stanley says, well, I'm the same be around sad people because they make her sad. Stanley says, well, I'm the same way around horny people. Great. Thanks. Thanks for that tidbit, Stanley. Kelsey A. from Canada had a Phyllis question.
好吧，大家猜怎么着？我们在上周刚刚播出的对菲利丝的采访中得知了她是如何被选中在皮克斯电影《头脑特工队》中扮演忧忧的！所以如果你错过了，一定要回去听听看。如果你只是想听听某人的声音，让你的心中充满幸福感，那就听听这个采访吧，因为菲利丝是一个非常棒、充满爱心的人，而这在她身上闪耀着光芒。嗯-hmm。我们最近一直在和很多人聊天。
Kelsey noted that Phyllis played the character Sadness in the Pixar movie Inside Out and wanted to know if the way she acted sad in this scene when she says, I can't be around sad people, they make me sad. Is that why she got picked for the role in the Pixar movie? Because she thought she sounded just like sadness when she said it. Kelsey, I did too. It was the first thing I thought of when I heard her say it. Me too.
我们确实聊了很多。我们最近超级健谈。好吧，每个人突然之间都在同一时间有空了。杰克，菲利丝，鲍勃。我知道。皮特现在来上班了，他和亚伦交换了一个小微笑。然后亚伦有一个访谈镜头，说她和皮特一直在交往，但为了照顾安吉拉的感受，他们保密着。另外，有那样一个小小的秘密恋情发生也挺刺激的。她说她看到了皮特的屁股，太棒了。索尼娅·达拉我们收到了来自俄勒冈州塞勒姆市的艾莉·M.的一个粉丝提问，她说：
Well, guess what, everybody? We found out how Phyllis got picked to be sadness in the Pixar movie Inside Out during our interview with her that just ran last week. So if you missed it, definitely go back and check it out. If you just want just to listen to someone and just feel like happiness in your heart, listen to this interview because Phyllis is such a wonderful, loving person and it just shines through. Mm-hmm. We've been talking to a lot of people lately.
我的问题是，当亚伦说“我是说，我看到了皮特的屁股，太棒了”。我猜艾莉和她的丈夫保罗多年来一直对这句台词的意思争论不休。什么？艾莉真的很希望我们能帮忙澄清一下，无论是通过剧本还是给出我们的意见。艾莉的丈夫认为亚伦是在说看到皮特的屁股很恶心，因为她的角色有时有点像小孩子。但艾莉认为亚伦对看到皮特的屁股感到很高兴。
We have. We've been super chatty. Well, everybody became available at the same time all of a sudden. Jake, Phyllis, Bob. I know. Pete now arrives to work and he and Erin kind of share a little smile. And then Erin has a talking head that said that she and Pete have been seeing one another, but they're keeping it a secret out of consideration for Andy. Plus, it's also kind of hot to have that little secret romance happening. And she says she saw Pete's butt and it's sick. SONIA DARA We got a fan question from Allie M. in Salem, Oregon who said,
我们有什么看法？她显然对看到他的屁股感到很高兴。非常明显的高兴。太棒了（sick），意思是像“太棒了（sick）”，就像很赞一样。是的，就像超酷一样。就像超酷。另外，在剧本围读的草稿中，因为我的数字杂乱文件夹里还留着它，
my question is when Erin says, I mean, I saw Pete's butt, it's sick. I guess Allie and her husband Paul have been disagreeing about the meaning of this line for years. What? Allie is really hoping that we can help clear it up, either using the script or giving our opinions. Allie's husband thinks Erin is saying that seeing Pete's butt was gross, based on her character being kind of childlike at times. But Allie thinks that Erin was happy about seeing Pete's butt.
上面写的是，她说的台词是“我见过他的屁股，太疯狂了”。哦。我不知道为什么最后变成了“太棒了”，但这显然是一个夸奖，保罗。艾莉，我希望我们能帮你们解决这个争议。我知道你们不用再为这个争吵了。不。艾莉，你是对的。
What are our thoughts? She's clearly happy about seeing his butt. Very clearly happy. It's sick, meaning like sick, like sick is awesome. Yeah, like rad. Like rad. Also in the table draft, because I still had it in my digital clutter,
你是对的，亚伦喜欢她所看到的。帕姆现在走到复印机旁。在凯文看到之前，她迅速拿走了一张纸，我们发现她在费城有一个工作面试。是一家房地产公司。吉姆为她安排的，你知道她有点紧张。她觉得这一切进展得比她预期的要快一点。另外，她举起她的简历说，我的简历可以写在一张便利贴上。哦，女士，这可是粉丝来信大爆发啊。我看到了。大家对帕姆的简历有很多想法。
it had her say, I've seen his butt, it's nuts. Oh. And I don't know why it ended up being it's sick, but this was clearly a compliment, Paul. Ali, I hope we help settle that. I know you guys don't have to argue about it anymore. No. Ali, you are right.
他们确实有很多想法。所以我去邓德百科（Dunderpedia）上查了一下。他们把实际的简历排版列出来了。她列出的工作经历只有在邓德·米弗林当接待员和在邓德·米弗林当办公室经理。她的学历列的是高中和普瑞特艺术学院。然后她列出的兴趣是我的孩子、艺术和绘画。孩子、艺术和绘画。孩子、艺术和绘画。我们来剖析一下。来自加利福尼亚州卡马里奥的泰伦·吉说，
You are right, Erin liked what she saw. Pam is now over at the copier. She quickly takes a piece of paper before Kevin can see it and we find out she has a job interview in Philly. It's for a real estate company. Jim set it up for her and you know she's kind of nervous. She feels like this is all moving a little faster than she expected. Plus, she holds up her resume and she says, my resume could fit on a Post-it note. Oh lady, this was a fan mail flurry. I saw. People have lots of thoughts about Pam's resume.
我们需要谈谈帕姆的简历为什么只有两行，因为她实际上当过接待员、两家不同公司的销售员以及办公室经理。她曾在普瑞特担任过宿舍助理（RA）。她绝对可以写满整整一页，描述她每一份工作的职责、她的壁画工作。然后来自英国兰开夏郡普雷斯顿的大卫·H.
They really do. So I looked it up on Dunderpedia. They had the actual resume sort of laid out. And all she lists for her work experience is being a receptionist at Dunder Mifflin and being an office manager at Dunder Mifflin. For her education, she lists high school and Pratt. And then she says her interests are my children, art and painting. Children, art and painting. Children, art and painting. Let's break this down. Taryn Gee from Camarillo, California said,
也想知道为什么这份简历没有包含她的任何销售经验。来自加拿大不列颠哥伦比亚省邦伯里的莉安·J.说，在第八季第五集里，帕姆提到她在女妖酒吧（Banshee Pub）工作过，在那里她看到了黑衣人。那也是另一份可以帮她丰满一下简历的工作。是的。我是记得这个的。
we need to talk about Pam's resume being only two lines because she has actually been a receptionist, a salesperson at two different companies and an office manager. She was an RA at Pratt. She could absolutely be filling an entire page with a description of duties of each of these jobs, her mural work. And then David H. from Preston, Lankenshire,
当我看到这里时，我想，等等，记得吉姆和帕姆关于鬼魂有过一场辩论吗，因为她在一家餐馆工作过，然后她看到了一个鬼魂？是的。她还上过大学，但这上面没有列出来。你知道吗？我从这份贴出来的简历中得出一个理论，那就是帕姆真的想要这份工作吗？看起来
England also would like to know why this resume does not include any of her sales experience. And Leanne J. from Burnbury, British Columbia, Canada says in season eight, episode five, Pan mentions that she worked at the Banshee Pub, where she saw the man in black. That's another job that could have helped bulk up her resume a bit. Yes. I mean, I remembered that.
她并没有在这份简历上花太多功夫。就像从一开始她就在消极怠工一样。我是说，也许她并没有意识到自己在这么做，这就像是一种潜意识的事情。嗯，有些人说也许她不想谈论她在迈克尔·斯考特造纸公司的经历，因为那段经历并不是真正的公司。也许她不想谈论销售经历，因为她不擅长，她也不想要那种工作了。我不知道。但你得把所有的经历都写在简历上。你得把所有的经历都写上。听着，作为一个有抱负的演员，我们知道怎么给简历注水。回顾过去。相信我，我在某些大学演出里只有两个角色，但它看起来就像我
When I was watching this, I thought, wait, remember Jim and Pam had this whole debate about ghosts because she worked at a restaurant and she saw a ghost? Yeah. She also went to college, and that's not listed. You know what? I had a theory from this posted resume is that does Pam even want this job? Doesn't
巡回世界进行表演一样。但你必须把所有的技能都和这些工作联系起来列出来。而帕姆什么都没做。比如她没有写技能、管理人员、有主观能动性之类的任何职场流行词。她没有在这上面花太多心思。好吧，听着，这还不是关于帕姆简历唯一的争议。来自德克萨斯州圣安东尼奥的GGF说，我注意到帕姆在她的简历中没有使用牛津逗号。女士们，你们对此有什么要说的？你们对牛津逗号有什么看法？
look like she put a lot of effort in this resume. Like from the beginning she's kind of tanking it. I mean maybe she's not aware that she's doing that it's like a subconscious thing. Well some people said maybe she doesn't want to talk about her time at Michael Scott Paper Company because it kind of wasn't really real. Maybe she doesn't want to talk about her time at Michael Scott Paper Company because it kind of wasn't really real. Maybe she doesn't want to talk about sales because she wasn't good at it and she doesn't want that kind of job again. I don't know. But you put all the things on a resume. You put all the things. Listen, as an aspiring actor, we know how to pad a resume. Going back. Believe me, I'd had like two roles in some college shows, but it looked like I
哦，不，我觉得好糟糕。我不知道那是什么。我完全不知道那是什么。我得去查一下。我替我们查了。好的。当我查的时候，以下是出现的一些内容。
toured the world performing. But you have to list like all of your skills in association with these jobs. And Pam doesn't do any of that. Like she doesn't say like skills, managing people, any takes initiative, any of the buzzwords. She didn't put a lot of thought into it. Well listen, that wasn't the only controversy about Pam's resume. GGF from San Antonio, Texas said, I notice that Pam does not use the Oxford comma in her resume. What do you ladies have to say about this and what are your opinions of the Oxford comma?
你知道它怎么给你提供诸如建议的问题吗？当然。它上面写着，有必要使用牛津逗号吗？为什么牛津逗号是有争议的？为什么它是有争议的？为什么人们不喜欢牛津逗号？哇。好的。
Oh no, I feel so bad. I don't know what it is. I had no idea what it was. I have to Google it. I Googled it for us. Okay. When I Googled it, here are some of the things that came up.
我从“什么是牛津逗号”开始查。我觉得我们应该了解一下。吉吉，我是说，多亏了你的问题，我觉得我们马上要在这里上一堂真正的教育课了。好的。我不知道在语法专家的世界里，这是一个多么热门的话题。但根据我在OxfordRoyale.com上找到的一篇文章，他们列出了牛津逗号的利弊。文章开头引用了林恩·特鲁斯（Lynn Truss）的一句话，她是一本名为《Eats, Shoots, and Leaves》（意为“吃、射击和离开”，一本关于标点符号的书）的作者，这本书被认为是标点符号圣经。
You know how it gives you like suggested questions? Sure. It says, is it necessary to use the Oxford comma? Why is the Oxford comma controversial? Why is it controversial? Why don't people like the Oxford comma? Wow. Okay.
你知道它不是会给出那种建议的问题吗？当然。它上面写着，有必要使用牛顿逗号吗？为什么牛顿逗号会引起争议？为什么会有争议？为什么人们不喜欢牛顿逗号？哇。好吧。
I started with what is an Oxford comma? I think that we should know. Gigi, I mean, I feel like we're about to have a real education here thanks to your question. All right. I had no idea what a hot button topic this was in the world of grammar experts. But according to an article that I found on OxfordRoyale.com, they list the pros and cons of the Oxford comma. The article starts with a quote by Lynn Truss, who is the author of a book called Eats, Shoots, and Leaves, which is considered the punctuation Bible.
我从什么是牛顿逗号开始？我觉得我们应该了解一下。吉吉，我的意思是，我觉得多亏了你的问题，我们马上就要上一课了。好的。我不知道在语法专家世界里，这是一个多么热门的话题。但是根据我在 OxfordRoyale.com 上找到的一篇文章，他们列出了牛顿逗号的优缺点。文章开头引用了林恩·特拉斯的话，她是一本名为《吃、射击与离开》的作者，这本书被认为是标点符号圣经。
Oh. Mm-hmm. And here's what she said about the Oxford comma, quote, There are people who embrace the Oxford comma and people who don't, and I'll just say this, never get between these people when a drink has been taken. Oh my gosh. Wait, is the Oxford comma, does it look like a semicolon? No, no, no, it's a comma. So here's how it works. If you're listing multiple things in a sentence,
哦。嗯哼。这是她对牛津逗号的评价，原话是：“有人拥护牛津逗号，也有人反对，我只想说一句话：当大家都在喝酒时，千万别夹在这两派人中间。”我的天啊。等等，牛津逗号，它长得像分号吗？不，不，不，它就是个逗号。它是这么用的：如果你在句子中列举多项内容，
do you put a comma after every single one, even before and, or do you leave the comma out when you get to the and? So for example, this sentence, her favorite foods were chocolate comma, marshmallows comma, cake and chicken. Or do you say with an Oxford comma, her favorite foods were chocolate, comma, marshmallows, comma, cake, comma, and chicken?
你是会在每一个项目后面都加一个逗号，甚至在“和”字前面也加，还是在写到“和”字时就把逗号省去？比如这个句子：她最喜欢的食物是巧克力（逗号）、棉花糖（逗号）、蛋糕和鸡肉。或者，你用牛津逗号会说：她最喜欢的食物是巧克力（逗号）、棉花糖（逗号）、蛋糕（逗号）和鸡肉？
I was taught to put a comma before and. So there's a comma after each word listed even before the word and. It's very American of you. Okay, I was as well I didn't realize that You know that would be considered controversial but I guess some people feel like if you put the comma before and that it's sort of like overly pendantic and
我受的教育是在“和”字前面加逗号。所以在列出的每个词后面都有一个逗号，甚至在“和”字前面也有。你可真够美国化的。好吧，我也是。我以前没意识到这会被认为是有争议的，但我想有些人觉得如果在“和”字前加逗号，就显得有点过分迂腐，
You can sound pompous and hyper-correct because it is possible for people to know what you mean without using the comma. So you don't need to be all snooty about it. And is it more common in America than in other countries? It is. However, this article went through and even looked back at like historical texts and here's what they found, that it is generally more common among American style guides than British ones.
而且会让你听起来自命不凡、矫枉过正，因为不用逗号大家也能听懂你的意思。所以没必要在这事儿上显得清高。这在美国比在其他国家更常见吗？确实如此。不过，这篇文章甚至回溯查阅了一些历史文本，他们的发现是：与英国相比，美国的文体指南普遍更常用它。
The Times and The Economist, for instance, are both against its use, but many well-known American guides such as the Chicago Manual of Style advocate it. However, the Associated Presp style book does not use the Oxford comma. So the comma that comes before the and is known as the Oxford comma. Correct.
比如《泰晤士报》和《经济学人》都反对使用它，但许多知名的美国指南，如《芝加哥老式手册》，则主张使用它。不过，《美联社风格手册》不用牛津逗号。所以，“和”字前面的那个逗号就叫牛津逗号。没错。
I see now. And so the controversy is whether to use it or not. That's right. But French, German, and Italian do not use the Oxford comma, and there's no controversy about not using it. The Italians don't use it? Did I say Italians? That using it. The Italians don't use it? Did I say Italians? That's right.
我明白了。所以争议点就在于用还是不用。没错。但法语、德语和意大利语不用牛津逗号，而且不用它也没有什么争议。意大利人不 Also不用？我说意大利人了吗？不用它。意大利人不 Also不用？我说意大利人了吗？没错。
The Italians. The Italians don't use it either. Either. What is happening? I want to just real quickly give an argument for the Oxford Kava, if I may, if it won't just tick people off. So I gave you my sample sentence, which is like her favorite foods were chocolate,
意大利人。意大利人也不用。也不用。这到底是怎么回事？如果可以的话，如果不会惹大家生气的话，我想简单为牛津逗号辩护一下。我刚才举了我的例句，比如她最喜欢的食物是巧克力、
marshmallows, cake, and chicken. What if her favorite foods were chocolate, marshmallows, chicken, and waffles? Without the comma, it sounds like her favorite foods were chocolate, marshmallows, chicken, and waffles. Or her favorite foods were chocolate, marshmallows, chicken, and waffles. Or her favorite foods were chocolate, marshmallows, chicken, and waffles. Not chicken and waffles. You really need the comma so that we know what her favorite foods were. I support this argument. You know what I'm saying? I do, sort of. To sum this up, I did look up should you use the Oxford comma on a resume, and it said, while it's not mandatory, using it on a resume can enhance clarity, especially when listing
棉花糖、蛋糕和鸡肉。如果她最喜欢的食物是巧克力、棉花糖、鸡肉和华夫饼呢？如果没有逗号，听起来就像她最喜欢的食物是巧克力、棉花糖、鸡肉和华夫饼。或者她最喜欢的食物是巧克力、棉花糖、鸡肉和华夫饼。或者她最喜欢的食物是巧克力、棉花糖、鸡肉和华夫饼。而不是鸡肉加华夫饼。你真的需要这个逗号，我们才知道她最喜欢的食物到底是什么。我支持这个论点。你知道我在说什么吧？我懂，算是吧。总而言之，我确实查了一下简历上到底该不该用牛津逗号，上面说，虽然这不是强制性的，但在简历上使用它可以提高清晰度，特别是在列出
multiple skills or job responsibilities. So maybe Pam should have used it. Well, Pam maybe should have just put more effort into this resume. There's that too. All right. I hope you all enjoyed learning about the Oxford comma. I very much did.
多项技能或工作职责时。所以帕姆也许真该用一下。好吧，帕姆也许真该在这份简历上多花点心思。也有这方面的原因。好了。希望大家喜欢了解牛津逗号。我非常喜欢。
I now know it and I'll never forget it. Thank you, Gigi. Well, let's take a break because when we come back, I had the table draft for this episode in my email and there was a phone call between Pam and Brian and I think I need to share it with you. What? Yeah.
我现在知道了，而且永远不会忘。谢谢你，吉吉。好了，我们休息一下，因为等我们回来时，我的邮箱里有这一集的剧本初稿，里面有帕姆和布莱恩的一通电话，我觉得我得跟大家分享一下。什么？对啊。
Oh boy, I don't remember this. All right, we'll be right back. We'll be right back, and I'm gonna have a cheese stick, some crackers, and my iced tea. Sounds good. All right, we're back. And, Ange, what would Pam have done after looking at her resume? So in the table draft, right at the end of this Pam talking head about her resume, she
天哪，我不记得这个了。好吧，我们马上回来。我们马上回来，我要去吃根奶酪棒、几块饼干，再来杯冰茶。听起来不错。好了，我们回来了。安吉，帕姆看完简历后会做什么？所以在剧本初稿里，就在帕姆这段关于简历的独白快结束时，她
gets a phone call. It read like this. Pam's cell phone rings. Pam checks it. She shows it to the camera. It reads, Brian. Pam sighs and says to the documentarian, Sorry, I've got to take this. She gets up and walks out. The camera stays on the empty chair, but we can hear Pam's audio through her mic pack. Oh. Pam says, Hey, Brian, how are you guys holding up? Oh, good. And Alyssa agreed to go with you? Well, that's it.
接到了一个电话。内容是这样的。帕姆的手机响了。帕姆看了一眼。她把它展示给镜头看。上面写着：布莱恩。帕姆叹了口气，对纪录片拍摄人员说：“对不起，我得接个电话。”她站起身走了出去。镜头停留在空椅子上，但我们可以通过她的麦克风听到帕姆的声音。哦。帕姆说：“嘿，布莱恩，你们最近怎么样？哦，挺好。阿莉莎答应跟你一起去了吗？”好了，就这些。
And that's all you hear. Oh. So Brian is calling her with updates. On his relationship. Mm-hmm. Which is interesting to me, because in this couple's friendship, it's not Pam and Alyssa talking about
你听到的就只有这些。哦。所以布莱恩打电话给她是为了通报最新情况。关于他的感情状况。嗯哼。这让我觉得很有意思，因为在这对夫妻的朋友中，不是帕姆和阿莉莎在讨论
Brian and Alyssa's marriage, it's Pam and Brian talking about it, which is not liking it, I don't like that. Well, Pam is Brian's confidant. Which is not appropriate, in my opinion. It was in the table draft. It didn't even make it to the shooting draft and we never shot it. That's right.
布莱恩和阿莉莎的婚姻，而是帕姆和布莱恩在讨论，这让人感觉不太舒服，我不喜欢这样。好吧，帕姆是布莱恩的知己。在我看来，这很不合适。初稿里是这样的。甚至都没进正式拍摄的剧本，我们也从没拍过。没错。
But I was curious, like, when I saw it, I was like, oh, I guess they did have a moment where they were going to just give us a little tidbit about what was happening there. Mm-hmm. Well, instead, we have a scene with Dwight talking on the phone to Moe's. And you think he's describing how Moe's should feed one of the animals on the farm, but he's actually referring to their aunt Shirley. Yeah. Then, Dwight is going to surprise Angela in the break room.
但我很好奇，当时我看到它时心想，哦，我想他们确实有过这样一个时刻，打算跟我们透露一点那边发生的事情。嗯哼。好吧，相反，我们看到的是德怀特跟莫斯打电话的一幕。你以为他在描述莫斯应该怎么喂农场里的某只动物，但实际上他指的是他们的阿姨雪莉。对。然后，德怀特要在休息室给安吉拉一个惊喜。
He says you really need to take breaks more often because he's been waiting behind the vending machine for like 45 minutes now. And this is when he's going to say, I need your help with my Aunt Shirley. They need someone to clean her. The last nurse was maybe poisoned. Angela does not want to do this. No. But Dwight reminds her that, you know, she kind of owes him. We had a lot of fan questions about this scene, Angela. It's very funny. Dierin T. from Poland said, was the description of Aunt Shirley's body parts scripted?
他说你真的需要更频繁地休息，因为他在自动售货机后面已经等了大概45分钟了。就在这个时候，他说出了这句话：“我需要你帮我照顾雪莉阿姨。他们需要有人给她擦洗身体。上一个护士可能被毒死了。”安吉拉不想干这活儿。不。但德怀特提醒她，你知道的，她多少欠他个人情。安吉拉，我们收到了很多关于这场戏的粉丝提问。这非常搞笑。来自波兰的迪林·T问：雪莉阿姨身体部位的描写是剧本里写好的吗？
When Dwight talks about the prehensile wing, you can see that Angela's trying to hide her smile. We also got a fan question from Brittany M. in Daytona Beach, Florida, who said, when Dwight asks Angela to help bathe his aunt and describes the wing, it looks like you're both about to break. Everybody would like to know how much of this was scripted, Angela. Talk to us about this scene. I loved this scene.
当德怀特谈到抓握翼时，你可以看到安吉拉正试图掩饰笑容。我们还收到了来自佛罗里达州代托纳比奇的布里特妮·M的粉丝提问，她说：当德怀特请安吉拉帮忙给他阿姨洗澡并描述那个翅膀时，看起来你们俩都快笑场了。大家都想知道这里面有多少是剧本写好的，安吉拉。跟我们聊聊这场戏吧。我超爱这场戏。
I mean, you know, first of all, when Dwight says, you owe me, he's talking about the whole thing where his friend and the pipe. Yes. And the kneecapping of Oscar, right? So he thing where his friend and the pipe. Yes. And the knee capping of Oscar, right? So he's gonna play that card now. Yeah. And this is why Angela agrees to do it.
我是说，首先，当德怀特说“你欠我的”时，他说的是他朋友和管子的那件事。对。还有对奥斯卡膝盖下手那件事，对吧？所以他现在要打这张牌了。对。这就是为什么安吉拉同意这么做。
We had so much fun shooting these scenes. I wanted to share with you guys how it was described in the shooting draft. It said, interior break room, Angela goes to the snack machine, Dwight is waiting behind the door. Well, when we got to the scene and we started rehearsing it, it didn't work that Dwight was behind the door. I guess the camera could see him. I remember it just didn't work. So we had this
我们拍这些戏时开心极了。我想跟大家分享一下拍摄剧本里是怎么描述这一段的。上面写着：内景，休息室，安吉拉走向零食售货机，德怀特正躲在门后面等待。嗯，当我们拍到这场戏并开始排练时，德怀特躲在门后面根本行不通。我猜镜头能拍到他。我记得就是行不通。所以我们在现场想出了一个
idea in the moment that Dwight would hide behind the other vending machine in the corner. So funny. And when rain as Dwight popped around the corner when we were rehearsing, it did sort of startle me. And so we just went with that. That reaction was not scripted where I was like, Dwight, none of that was scripted. And then Rain started going off script when it got to the part where he was describing the flap. Yeah. Oh my gosh. So in the shooting draft, it was written simply like this. Dwight says, this is an old woman, Angela. It's all hanging out. I don't even recognize some of the parts anymore.
主意：德怀特躲在角落里的另一台自动售货机后面。太搞笑了。当扮演德怀特的雷恩在我们排练时从拐角处突然冒出来时，确实把我吓了一跳。于是我们就顺着这个演下去了。我当时说“德怀特，天哪”那个反应根本不是剧本里写的。那些全都不是剧本写的。然后雷恩开始在描述那个垂肉的桥段时自由发挥了。对。哦天哪。所以在拍摄剧本里，它是这样简单写的。德怀特说：“这是个老太婆，安吉拉。全都耷拉着。有些部位我都快认不出来了。”
There's one hanging out in particular, some sort of flap. And then Angela just says, okay, fine. Yeah. And Dwight says, I think I know what it was, but why is there only one? And Angela goes, Dwight! And leaves. Everything else you see was improvised. Rain started really having some fun with this flap. I could barely hold it together, but I would have to improvise my reactions to what he was improvising. And John just let us play around and it was so much fun.
“特别有个部位垂在外面，某种类似于垂肉的东西。”然后安吉拉只说了一句：“好吧，行吧。”对。然后德怀特说：“我想我知道那是什么，但为什么只有一个？”安吉拉就说：“德怀特！”然后离开了。你看到的其他所有内容都是即兴发挥的。雷恩开始拿这个垂肉大开玩笑。我简直快憋不住了，但我必须对他的即兴发挥做出即兴的反应。约翰就让我们自由发挥，真的太好玩了。
And you guys are absolutely right. I had to look away. I kind of bend over because I just started laughing. I think it's so clear that the two of you were having fun in this scene. And we all love Dwight and Angela together. And we haven't gotten to see as much of it as I would have liked over these last couple of seasons.
你们绝对没猜错。我不得不把视线移开。我有点弯下腰去，因为我实在忍不住笑出声了。我觉得你们两个人在这一场里玩得太开心了，这太明显了。我们所有人都很喜欢德怀特和安吉拉这对组合。在过去这几季里，我们没能看到那么多他们的对手戏，其实我还挺希望多看点的。
So this whole episode, but this scene that kicks it off is just so, so fun. Thanks. Well, we really, really had a good time. And I know somewhere there was a blooper of me because I could not keep it together. Back in the main bullpen, Pam was gonna get her coat and she's gonna leave.
所以整集下来，尤其是这场拉开序幕的戏，真的是太有意思了。谢谢。嗯，我们确实玩得超级开心。我知道某个地方有我的NG镜头，因为我实在憋不住笑。回到主要办公区，帕姆要去拿外套准备离开。
And I'm calling this SAS exit number one. Yep. At six minutes and two seconds, when Andy says, where are you going? She replies, not on a three month boat trip. SASS Exit. Oh my gosh, she doesn't even break her stride. No, then Dwight and Angela leave as well.
我把这叫做“傲娇退场”第一号。没错。在6分02秒时，当安迪问“你去哪儿？”她回答说：“又不是去进行三个月的乘船旅行。”傲娇退场。哦天哪，她甚至连步子都没停。没有，然后德怀特和安吉拉也离开了。
And Andy's like, what, so everybody can just leave whenever they want now? I love my snarky smile. Six minutes, 15 seconds. SASS Exit number two. My snarky smile. Six minutes, 15 seconds. Sass exit number two. My snarky smile was not scripted. I just wanted to do it. Well, at the end of this scene, at six minutes and 23 seconds, right after Andy says, I'm still the boss, it cuts over to Erin at reception. And I noticed this thing over her shoulder. I don't know how long it's been there. It was the first time I noticed it.
安迪一副“什么，难道现在所有人想走就能走吗？”的表情。我喜欢我那个尖酸刻薄的微笑。6分15秒。傲娇退场第二号。我那个尖酸刻薄的微笑。6分15秒。傲娇退场第二号。我那个傲娇的微笑可不是剧本里写的。我就是想这么演。好吧，在这场戏的结尾，在6分钟23秒时，就在安迪说“我还是老板”之后，镜头切到了在前台的艾琳。我注意到她肩膀后面有个东西。我不知道这东西在那儿呆多久了。这是我第一次注意到它。
It's like a stuffed animal, peanut or a basketball. It has like this red hat and red shoes. What is it? How long has it been there? I couldn't tell what it was. I was like, is it an M&M? Is it a peanut M&M? Is it a peanut? It has a hat.
它就像个毛绒玩具，一颗花生还是一个篮球。它戴着个红帽子，穿着红鞋子。那是什么？它在那儿呆多久了？我看不出那是什么。我当时想：是个M&M巧克力豆吗？是个花生M&M巧克力豆吗？是一颗花生吗？它戴着帽子。
Yeah, and shoes. And shoes. And I think arms. But I'm gonna keep looking for it. I'm gonna track it. Track the peanut. Track the peanut hat person. I will. Well, Aaron is gonna bring Andy some messages from his clients and he says, you know what? He doesn't want anything to do with work. And she's like, well, all I want to do is work. Yeah. And he says, you can keep my blue sweater. I know you loved it so much.
对，还有鞋子。还有鞋子。我想还有胳膊。但我会继续找它的。我要追踪它。追踪那颗花生。追踪那个花生帽子人。我会的。好吧，艾琳要给安迪送一些客户留下的留言，他说，你知道吗？他现在什么工作都不想干。她说，好吧，我只想工作。对。然后他说：“你可以留着我的蓝色毛衣。我知道你以前超喜欢它的。”
And she says, I donated it. Yeah. How do we feel about that? Do we think it's like, okay that she donated it? Why wouldn't she just give it back to him I think she should have just packed up his things that she didn't want and given it to him yeah yeah um at seven minutes and eight seconds I have a new desk item catch again everybody maybe it's been there a while but I just noticed it
她说：“我把它捐了。”对。我们对这事儿怎么看？我们觉得她把它捐了这事儿……还行吧？她为什么不直接还给他呢？我觉得她本来应该把那些他不要的东西打包好还给他的。对，对，嗯……在7分08秒时，我又发现了一个桌上摆件，大家注意看，也许它已经在那里呆了一段时间了，但我刚注意到它。
there is a bell on Andy's desk with an anchor attached to the top of it. I saw it too. Are these items new or are we just seeing them for the first time? I have not seen the bell. Okay. I feel like Peanut Man has been there before, but I don't know.
安迪的桌上有一个铃铛，顶部还连着一个船锚。我也看到了。这些东西是新摆的，还是我们只是第一次看到？我没见过这个铃铛。好吧。我觉得花生人以前就在那儿，但我也不确定。
All right. Andy now goes to the annex. He wants to vent, you know, with the guys. He tells them, we're in the bro zone layer, okay? Nard dog plop and Clark or Posey, AKA clockwork orange. Here's the sitch. Erin dumped me, natch. But she got rid of my blue sweater, which is her favorite.
好了。安迪现在去了附楼。你知道的，他想跟这几个家伙吐吐槽。他告诉他们：“我们现在处于哥们儿安全区，懂吗？纳德狗、普洛普和克拉克或波西，又名发条橙。情况是这样的：艾琳把我甩了，不出所料。但她把我的蓝色毛衣给扔了，那可是她最喜欢的。”
Is she moving on a little faster or am I being a total psycho? Plop, you go first. I loved everything about this dialogue. Same. I can only imagine how much fun it was to write for Andy Bernard. She dumped me. Natch. I mean, who talks like that?
“我是不是有点太快翻篇了，还是说我彻底精神失常了？普洛普，你先说。”这段对话里的所有内容我都爱。一样。我简直无法想象给安迪·伯纳德写台词会有多开心。“她把我甩了。不出所料。”我是说，谁会这么说话？
Also, there were alts for Clark Raposi and Clark Wark Orange. What were they? There was Zero Clark Thirty, Clark Wing, Clarkinson's Disease. Okay. During this Brozone layer meeting, you know, Clark is going to say, hey, why don't you just enjoy this freedom? And Andy says, last night I ordered a pizza and I ate it over the sink like a rat. Yeah.
另外，关于克拉克·拉波西和发条橙克拉克，其实还有其他备选台词。都是些什么？有“零克拉克三十”、“克拉克之翼”、“克拉克森病”。好吧。在这个哥们儿安全区会议期间，你知道的，克拉克会说：“嘿，你为什么不享受这种自由呢？”安吉说：“昨晚我点了个披萨，像只老鼠一样趴在水槽边把它吃完了。”对。
Well, we had a fan question about this scene from Jen S. in Morgan Hill, California. She said, my absolute favorite line of this episode is after Andy leaves and Clark turns to Pete and says, I'll give you $100 to wear that sweater to work tomorrow. Yeah, also. Jen wanted to know if that was scripted. It was not. Well, Clark Duke improvised that.
好吧，我们收到了一个来自加州摩根山镇的延·S提出的关于这场戏的粉丝提问。她说：“这一集里我绝对最喜欢的台词是，安迪离开后，克拉克转向皮特说：‘我给你100美元，明天穿那件毛衣去上班。’”对，还有。延想知道那是剧本写好的吗？并不是。好吧，那是克拉克·杜克即兴发挥的。
He's hilarious. Yeah. I also loved Jake's reaction because he had to improvise his reaction. Yep. Which is he just closes his eyes. I know. I know.
他太搞笑了。对。我也很喜欢杰克的反应，因为他必须即兴做出反应。没错。也就是他直接闭上了眼睛。我懂。我知道。我爱死办公室里皮特和克拉克的化学反应了。
I am loving the Pete Clark energy in the office. I really like them. I love Clark knowing a secret about Pete and that dynamic. All right. So next up, Dwight and Angela are going to arrive to Aunt Shirley's house. Angela, do you have a location breakdown for me? I do, Jenna. All right, so next up, Dwight and Angela are gonna arrive to Aunt Shirley's house. Angela, do you have a location breakdown for me? I do, Jenna.
我真的很喜欢他们。我喜欢克拉克知道皮特的一个秘密，以及他们之间的那种互动。好了。那么接下来，德怀特和安吉拉就要到达雪莉阿姨家了。安吉拉，你有外景地剖析要告诉我吗？我有，珍娜。好了，那么接下来，德怀特和安吉拉就要到达雪莉阿姨家了。安吉拉，你有外景地剖析要告诉我吗？我有，珍娜。
So Aunt Shirley's house was actually called Allen House. It's on the Warner Brothers Ranch. And you guys, when you drive into the Warner Brothers Ranch, there is the big fountain in the middle. That's the beginning of the Friends episode. Yes! Yeah. So I was beginning of the Friends episode. Yes! Yeah. Uh-huh.
所以雪莉阿姨的房子其实叫艾伦之屋。它在华纳兄弟牧场里。大家如果开车进华纳兄弟牧场，中间会看到那个巨大的喷泉。那就是《老友记》片头开始的地方。没错！对啊。所以看到那个我超级激动。
So I was very excited to see that. And then this house, this big yellow house, it really is a house. Of course, the inside they've made like a set, but from the exterior, it's just a beautiful big yellow house. In the back, there was a grassy area with a big tree, and there was a bench underneath the tree. And that's the day my daughter came to set, and she got to play in that grassy field. And I have a photo of her and I under the big tree. So I have special memories whenever I watch this episode. And it had a front porch that we filmed on,
然后这座房子，这座黄色的大房子，它真的就是栋房子。当然，里面被布置成了摄影棚的布景，但从外观来看，它就是一栋漂亮的大黄色房子。后面有一片长着大树的草坪，树底下还有一张长椅。那就是我女儿来片场的那天，她在那片草坪上玩耍。我还留着一张我和她在大树下的合影。所以每次看这一集，我都有特别的记忆。它还有一个我们拍过戏的前廊，
and then it had a back porch where they sort of kept all the camera gear and video village, and that's where I hung out with Jon Favreau. Now, did you shoot the outside of the house and the inside of the house in the same location? Yes, we filmed all the Warner Brothers ranch in one day. So on the call sheet that day, it was just me and Rain and Mary.
然后它还有一个后廊，他们把所有的摄影器材和视频村都放在那里，那是我跟乔恩·费儒闲晃的地方。那么，房子的外部和内部是在同一个地方拍的吗？是的，我们在华纳兄弟牧场一天之内把所有的戏都拍完了。所以那天的通告单上，只有我和雷恩还有玛丽。
You had the day off. It was Thursday. I tried to go to my digital clutter and see what I did that day. And I just don't have digital clutter. You get rid of s**t. I tried to go to my digital clutter and see what I did that day and I just don't have digital clutter. You get rid of s***. I do. I delete emails after I read them. I know you're good like that. I also quickly have a fakie bag catch at 8 minutes and 30 seconds as you're walking in. Dwight and Angela are each carrying two big brown paper
你那天放假。那是星期四。我试着查了一下我的数字垃圾文件，看看那天我都干了些什么。结果我根本没有数字垃圾文件。你把破烂都清理掉了。我试着查了一下我的数字垃圾文件，看看那天我都干了些什么，结果我根本没有数字垃圾文件。你把破烂都清理掉了。我确实清理了。我读完邮件就把它们删了。我知道你在这方面很有一套。我还要顺便提一下，在8分30秒你走进去的时候，我发现了一个道具纸袋的穿帮。德怀特和安吉拉手里各提着两个大纸袋。
bags. Those were the special bags that don't make a lot of sound, so the sound department likes them. And they have bought Shirley new clothes, and they're going to clean her up. They are. But as soon as Aunt Shirley sees the mentor, she calls Dwight Big City Dwight,
那是特制的纸袋，不会发出太大的声音，所以音响部门很喜欢它们。他们给雪莉买新衣服，准备给她收拾干净。他们确实这么做了。但雪莉阿姨一看到导师，就把德怀特叫作“大都市德怀特”，
and she inquires, what is up with this little kitchen witch? She's just a little kitchen witch. We got a fan question from Becca T. in Edmonton, Alberta, who said, I've been waiting for this episode because there is a restaurant in Bellingham, Washington called the Little Kitchen Witch. Oh, no way. Yeah. Becca said, my husband and I have visited the town often and it always makes me think of this episode. Becca wondered, is this a common phrase? Were there any candy bag alts for Aunt Shirley
她打听道，这个小厨房女巫是怎么回事？她只是个小小厨房女巫。我们收到了来自艾伯塔省埃德蒙顿的贝卡·T.的粉丝提问，她说，我一直在等这一集，因为华盛顿州贝林厄姆有一家餐厅叫“小厨房女巫”。哦，不会吧。是的。贝卡说，我和丈夫经常去那个小镇，这总是让我想起这一集。贝卡想知道，这是一个常见的短语吗？对于姨妈雪莉，有没有什么糖果袋替代方案
to call Angela anything else? Well Becca now that restaurants on my list of places I need to go to. It's closed. No. I looked it up it was only open for eight months. Oh. But it was known for its falafel schnitzel and other traditional Mediterranean dishes and it had five stars on Yelp. Well, dang it. I know. I wanted to go there with you and take a picture of you outside of it.
叫安吉拉别的名字？好吧，贝卡，现在那家餐厅在我的必去清单上了。它关门了。不会吧。我查了一下，它只开了八个月。哦。但它以炸豆丸子、炸肉排和其他传统地中海菜肴而闻名，在Yelp上有五星好评。好吧，该死。我知道。我想和你一起去，在它门外给你拍张照片。
Yes. I know. Well, farts. I guess we're just going to have to open like a little pub called the Little Kitchen Witch, Jenna. We really should. Just put it on our list of things to do. Okay.
是的。我知道。好吧，真扫兴。我想我们只能开一家叫“小厨房女巫”的小酒吧了，珍娜。我们真的应该这么做。把它列入我们的待办事项清单吧。好的。
Well, Becca, I went digging into the candy bag alts and there weren't any. It was scripted as Little Kitchen Witch in the shooting draft and that's what she said. I had not ever heard the phrase before. And when I Googled it, it is not part of the Merriam-Webster dictionary list of common phrases.
好吧，贝卡，我去翻找了糖果袋的替代台词，结果发现根本没有。拍摄剧本里写的台词就是“小厨房女巫”，她也就是这么说的。我以前从来没听过这个短语。当我用谷歌搜索时，它并不在韦氏词典的常用短语列表中。
Does Oprah doesn't break it down for us? She has not. Little kitchen witch. No. No. Oh, hey, just since we're off topic for a second. Oh. During our break, I thought of another fashion thing
奥普拉没有给我们详细解说过吗？她没有。小厨房女巫。没有。没有。哦，对了，既然我们刚才跑题了一会儿。哦。在休息的时候，我想到了另一件时尚单品
that I wanted to discuss besides the shack it. Is it shorts? No, it's about, oh my gosh, that just got a cackle from Jordan. It's not. It is about socks. Shocks, you want shocks? No, I did not know this.
我除了“衬衫夹克”之外还想讨论的东西。是短裤吗？不，是关于，哦天哪，这让乔丹大笑了起来。不是的。是关于袜子的。袜子，你想说袜子吗？不，我不知道这个。
A jock and a sock? This is a thing. Is what's a jocks? Like when you put your- I just was making it up. It's like a- No, I was thinking, you know what jocks is, is if you put your fella,
运动短裤托（jock）和袜子（sock）？这算是个梗。什么是运动短裤托？就像当你把你的——我刚刚瞎编的。这就像一个——不，我在想，你知道什么是运动短裤托吗，就是如果你把你的老二，
your little fella in a sock. Yes, that's what I was saying. Oh gosh, now I have two fashion things to talk about. They have this underwear for men and I got like served it by like an Instagram ad, I don't know how I got in this algorithm, they put their balls in a pocket. Isn't that just tighty-whities? No, tighty-whities don't have a speck. So when you put on this underwear, your balls go in a special pocket and it's meant to sort of keep them off your thighs. It's called a shock? No, it's just called underwear.
你的小老二塞进一只袜子。对，我刚才就是这么说的。哦天哪，现在我有两件时尚单品要聊了。他们为男士设计了这种内衣，我在Instagram的广告里刷到了，我不知道我是怎么进入这个算法的，他们的蛋蛋被放在一个口袋里。这不就是紧身白内裤吗？不，紧身白内裤没有那个袋子。所以当你穿上这种内衣时，你的蛋蛋会进到一个特殊的口袋里，这样做的目的是把它们和你的大腿隔开。这叫袜子包吗？不，它就叫内衣。
Oh. They missed an opportunity. They really did. But you put it in— A shock-it. What's a shock-it? It's a sock pocket for your balls. Oh.
哦。他们错失了一个好机会。他们真的错失了。但你把它塞进——一个袜子包。什么是袜子包？就是给你蛋蛋准备的袜子口袋。哦。
Well, I don't know. Talk to them about it. But that's a thing. You put them in their own little pocket. Carrier. Mm-hmm. I got Leah a pair for Father's Day. Oh, so you haven't given it to him yet.
好吧，我不知道。去和他们聊聊吧。但这确实是个东西。你把它们放在它们自己的小口袋里。运载工具。嗯哼。我给利娅买了一条作为父亲节礼物。哦，所以你还没送给他。
I haven't, not at the time when we recorded this. I'm not sure when this episode comes out. You'll have to let us know. Will I? I'm barely sure how. Actually, I don't know if I wanna know that information. But I got so, listen, I'll buy anything. I'm so bad.
还没送，在我们录制的时候还没。我不知道这集什么时候播出。你得让我们知道。是吗？我其实不太确定该怎么做。实际上，我不知道我是否想知道这个信息。但我买了，听着，我会买任何东西。我太糟糕了。
I bought that dumb thing that's supposed to, like, clean earwax out of your ear. I remember work I've got so many dumb things. I'm so Suggestible now. I've bought my husband a pair of underwear so he can put his balls in a pocket What am I doing? But listen, this isn't even what I wanted to talk about. I wanted to talk about socks I wanted to talk about okay. It wanted to talk about- Okay, it's okay. That there are all these videos now where they can tell if you are a millennial or a Gen Z or a Gen X by the socks you wear. Are you on TikTok?
我买了那个号称能清理耳朵里耳垢的蠢东西。我记得我工作时买过好多蠢东西。我现在太容易受暗示了。我给我丈夫买了一条内衣，好让他把蛋蛋放进口袋里。我在干什么？但听着，这甚至不是我想聊的。我想聊的是袜子。我想聊的是，好吧。我想聊的是——好吧，没关系。现在有各种各样的视频，它们能通过你穿的袜子看出你是千禧一代、Z世代还是X世代。你玩TikTok吗？
No, no. Sounds like a TikTok video. I know, but this is okay. So you see the socks I'm wearing right now, right? I'm wearing- The no-shows. No one wears those anymore No, kids don't wear them. They don't wear them. You have to it's ankle again. I know I have teenagers I know the socks that are hip I can't wrap my head around it by the way It took me so long to accept these dumb no-show socks that always slip down my heel. I hate them
不，不。听起来像个TikTok视频。我知道，但这个是这样的。所以你看到我脚上穿的袜子了吧，对吧？我穿的是——船袜。现在没人穿那个了。不，小屁孩不穿。他们不穿。你必须得穿，现在又流行露脚踝了。我知道，我有青少年，我知道什么样的袜子才叫时髦。我实在无法理解，顺便说一句。我花了那么长时间才接受这种总从脚后跟滑落的蠢船袜。我讨厌它们。
I refuse to wear them. Look at me. Oh, you have no socks Lady, what does no socks mean? I don't know any of it anymore. Times are changing. We can't keep up. Well, my last Instagram suggested ad was special underwear for thigh chafing. You know what? All of this is making me realize. What?
我拒绝穿它们。你看我。哦，你没穿袜子。大姐，没穿袜子是什么意思？我对这一切完全一无所知了。时代在变。我们跟不上了。好吧，我上一个Instagram推荐广告是专门防止大腿摩擦的内衣。你知道吗？这一切让我意识到。什么？
We clearly need like a fashion blogger podcast together. Oh, yeah. Where we break it down for you guys. But just, but just practical undergarments. And jackets. All right, Andy has a talking head. He wants to know why isn't Erin sad? Has she found someone new?
我们显然需要一起做个时尚博主播客。哦，耶。由我们来为你们解析。但只聊，只聊实用的内衣。还有夹克。好了，安迪有一个独白镜头。他想知道为什么艾琳不难过？她找到新欢了吗？
Is that why she's not that upset about this breakup? Oh, he says, you know, during a breakup, your mind goes to some dark places. Boy does it for Andy because he becomes a snoop. He does. Erin leaves front reception and leaves her phone. Andy grabs it and starts scrolling on it. Phyllis says, Andy, no good can come from snooping. Andy says, I'm not snooping.
这就是为什么她对这次分手没有那么沮丧的原因吗？哦，他说，你知道的，在分手期间，你的脑海会闪过一些阴暗的想法。安迪确实如此，因为他变成了一个窥探狂。他真的成了。艾琳离开前台时落下了手机。安迪抓起手机开始翻看。菲莉丝说，安迪，窥探可不会有什么好下场。安迪说，我没有在窥探。
Oscar's like, you're clearly snooping. Everyone is very upset by this except for Meredith. Creed's like, that's uncool. Meredith is like, tell us what it's on there. Like, Meredith wants to know all the dish. Well, guess what? He sees something. He sees that she has been texting with someone named Pete. He charges into the annex where Daryl Clark, Kevin, and Toby are, for some reason that we don't know, all gathered around Pete's desk and computer. Pete is the only one who's seated. Andy announces, my fears have been confirmed.
奥斯卡说，你分明就是在窥探。除了梅雷迪思，每个人对此都非常不满。克里德说，这太不地道了。梅雷迪思则说，快告诉我们上面写了什么。就像梅雷迪思想知道所有八卦一样。好吧，你猜怎么着？他看到了些东西。他看到她一直在和叫皮特的人发短信。他冲进附楼，那里有达雷尔、克拉克、凯文和托比，出于某种我们不知道的原因，他们都聚集在皮特的桌子和电脑周围。皮特是唯一坐着的人。安迪宣布，我的恐惧被证实了。
Erin is texting someone named Pete. Do any of you know someone by that name? Go to 10 minutes and 47 seconds seconds because the way Clark looks to camera when Andy says Pete is perfection. So good. And then Brian as Kevin says, Pete what? I know. That was improvised.
艾琳在和一个叫皮特的人发短信。你们有谁认识叫这个名字的人吗？把进度条拉到10分47秒，因为当安迪说出“皮特”时，克拉克看向镜头的表情简直绝了。太棒了。然后布莱恩饰演的凯文说，皮特是谁？我知道。那是即兴发挥的。
It was, yes. That was so good. Pete has a talking head where he says, oh my gosh, Andy's been calling me Plop for so long, he forgot my real name is Pete. This talking head was a bit extended in the shooting draft. Pete would have had another line where he said, I have probably about six minutes.
是的，确实是。太棒了。皮特有一个独白镜头，他说，哦天哪，安迪叫我“流质粪便”叫了那么久，他都忘了我真名叫皮特了。这个独白在拍摄剧本中稍微扩展了一点。皮特本来还有一句台词，他说，我大概还有六分钟的时间。
Before he figures it out. Well, he's right. Andy goes to the fridge and has his aha moment. He sees that lunch bag labeled Pete and he puts it all together. Yep. Pam is now going to arrive at Jim's office in Philly. She looks so cute.
在他反应过来之前。好吧，他是对的。安迪走到冰箱前，恍然大悟。他看到了那个贴着“皮特”标签的午餐袋，然后把一切都串联了起来。是的。帕姆现在要到达吉姆在费城的办公室了。她看起来太可爱了。
She's all dressed for her interview. Jim is wearing his Bluetooth device and they sort of have this little joke about it. He's like, I know I'm a douche, but look, I can do this with my hands. And he tells her she's gonna crush it. It's a sweet little moment. It really is. He's very excited for her. At 11 minutes and 30 seconds,
她盛装打扮去面试。吉姆戴着蓝牙耳机，他们对此开了个小玩笑。他说，我知道我像个混蛋，但你看，我可以用双手做这个。他告诉她，她会大获成功的。这是一个温馨的小时刻。确实如此。他为她感到非常兴奋。在11分30秒的时候，
I have a water bottle catch on Jim's desk. Someone left their water bottle. Oh, for real? Mm-hmm. Oh, that's so good. Yeah. It's like the Starbucks coffee on Game of Thrones. Exactly.
我发现吉姆的桌子上落了一个水瓶。有人落下了他们的水瓶。哦，真的吗？嗯哼。哦，太搞笑了。对。就像《权力的游戏》里的星巴克咖啡杯一样。完全正确。
We had a fan question from Jen H. in New York. Jen says, I have a Justice for Pam comment. Justice for Pam? Jen says, I've been waiting so long to ask this. Jim offers Darryl a job at his new company. Why on earth did he not ask Pam to join? Why couldn't she be the graphic designer at Athlead? It's wild because both Ryan and Michael believed in her art talents more than her own husband. Ryan asked her to make a logo in season four, episode two, and then in season four, episode five, Michael asked her to make a logo for the local ad. I bet Pam would have been much more receptive
我们收到了来自纽约延H.的粉丝提问。延说，我有一个“为帕姆讨回公道”的评论。为帕姆讨回公道？延说，我等了这么久才问出这个问题。吉姆在公司为达雷尔提供了一份工作。他为什么不叫上帕姆一起加入？她为什么不能成为Athlead的平面设计师？这太离谱了，因为瑞安和迈克尔都比她自己的丈夫更相信她的艺术才华。瑞安在第四季第二集让她制作一个标志，然后在第四季第五集，迈克尔让她为当地广告制作一个标志。我敢打赌，如果帕姆的梦想工作也在那里等着她，
to moving to Philly if her dream job was also waiting for her. Well, Jen, I hear you, but I do have some thoughts. I have some thoughts as well. First of all, Jim's business is not really making any money for this family, and I had read another fan comment that said they were really ticked off at Pam because she's not supporting Jim's, like, dream job.
她对搬去费城的接受度肯定会高得多。好吧，延，我理解你，但我有一些想法。我也有一些想法。首先，吉姆的业务并没有真正为这个家庭赚到什么钱，我之前看到过另一个粉丝的评论，说他们对帕姆非常生气，因为她不支持吉姆所谓的梦想工作。
Like, why didn't she just get a job in Philly? Her husband's making so much money at this great job, but Jim is not making any money. Remember, it's like this company has not had a profit. So if they're both working there, then no one's really bringing home a significant paycheck. Also, I don't think graphic design is Pam's dream job. I don't think she, she didn't love it. She dropped out because she didn't love it. Yeah, she dropped out because it wasn't what she thought it was going to be. I would also say this, if Jim and Pam are really hoping this business takes off, they can't move to a whole new city with their children and invest in property or a big enough rental for all of them without
比如，她为什么不在费城找份工作？她丈夫在这份伟大的工作上赚了那么多钱，但吉姆其实并没有赚到钱。记住，这家公司基本上还没有盈利。所以如果他们俩都在那里工作，那就真的没有人能拿回可观的薪水了。另外，我觉得平面设计并不是帕姆的梦想工作。我不觉得她，她并不热爱它。她半途而废就是因为她不热爱。是的，她退出了，因为这并不是她想象中的那样。我还要说的是，如果吉姆和帕姆真的希望这家公司起飞，他们带着孩子搬到一个全新的城市，在没有
knowing it's going to be a success. Right now, you would assume they don't really have a house payment and their kids are in school there. They have Pam's family, Jim's family nearby to help. So moving the whole family there, you're not gonna do that till you know that this is really going to take off. Yeah.
确定这会成功之前，是无法投资房产或租一套足够他们所有人住的大房子的。就目前而言，你可以假设他们其实没有房贷压力，他们的孩子也在当地上学。他们有帕姆的家人、吉姆的家人在附近帮忙。所以把整个全家搬过去，在确信这真的能起飞之前，你是不会这么做的。是的。
And I think there needs to be someone in this family who has like a stable income. But Jen, I appreciate you sticking up for Pam. Yes, Jen, I appreciate justice for Pam. I do see like down the road, there might be a job opportunity there for Pam. Yes, Jen, I appreciate justice for Pam. I do see, like, down the road there might be a job opportunity there for sure. Mm-hmm. Aunt Shirley has had plenty of schnaps and has fallen
而且我认为这个家里需要有人拥有一份稳定的收入。不过延，我很感激你为帕姆挺身而出。是的，延，我感谢为帕姆讨回公道。我确实觉得，在未来某天，那里肯定会有适合帕姆的工作机会。是的，延，我感谢为帕姆讨回公道。我确实觉得，在未来某天，那里绝对会有适合帕姆的工作机会。嗯哼。姨妈雪莉喝了太多杜松子酒，已经
asleep on the couch. Yeah, she hit the homemade schnaps really hard. Dwight says, okay, let's get her out in the yard and spray her down in a very tasteful, rustic, private shower. This is setting us up for the beginning of Moving On Part Two, for which we got a lot of fan questions. We'll get to it next week.
在沙发上睡着了。是的，她把自制杜松子酒喝得太猛了。德怀特说，好吧，我们把她弄到院子里去，用一个非常有品位、很简朴、很私密的淋浴喷头给她冲洗一下。这为《向前看》第二集的开场做好了铺垫，我们在这一集收到了很多粉丝的提问。我们下周再聊。
Meanwhile, Andy has called Pete into his office and he tells Pete that he has contracted chlamydia. Yeah. From Erin. From Erin. He's trying to get Pete's reaction and we talked about this with Jake Lacey. We did. He said that schlamydia was an improv by Ed. It was because in the script it said,
与此同时，安迪把皮特叫进办公室，告诉皮特他染上了衣原体感染（chlamydia）。是的。从艾琳那儿。从艾琳那儿。他试图试探皮特的反应，我们和杰克·莱西聊过这个。我们确实聊过。他说那个“衣原体”（schlamydia）是埃德即兴发挥的。确实如此，因为剧本里写的是，
Aaron gave me incurable syphilis. Pretty lame, huh? But then Ed improvised schlamydia. He did. And it made Jake laugh. I found the blooper. Let's hear it. I just got off the phone call. Ed improvised schlamydia. He did, and it made Jake laugh. I found the blooper.
艾琳给了我不可治愈的梅毒。真够逊的，对吧？但后来埃德即兴改成了“衣原体”（schlamydia）。他确实这么做了。这把杰克逗笑了。我找到了NG花絮。我们来听听。我刚挂了电话。埃德即兴发挥了“衣原体”。他确实这么做了，把杰克逗笑了。我找到了NG花絮。
Let's hear it. I just got off the phone with my doctor and it turns out that I contracted schlamydia. Come on, come on. Schlamydia. Oh man. Come on, come on, Slovenia. Oh man, well I guess they loved it so much, they kept it in and then they had to do it again and again so that Jake didn't laugh.
我们来听听。我刚和医生通过电话，结果发现我染上了衣原体（schlamydia）。拜托，拜托。衣原体。天哪。拜托，拜托，斯洛文尼亚。天哪，我想他们太喜欢这个梗了，所以把它保留了下来，然后他们不得不一遍又一遍地拍，好让杰克不再笑场。
Yes, and Jake told us that his proudest performance moment on the whole show was in this scene because there's that long pause and Pete says, you were gone. And Jake improvised that. And then in the moment, as Andy reacted and improvised, I knew it! And Jake just said it was the coolest thing.
是的，杰克告诉我们，他在整部剧中表现最自豪的时刻就是在这场戏里，因为当时有那个长长的停顿，然后皮特说，你当时不在。那是杰克即兴发挥的。然后在这个瞬间，安迪做出反应并即兴说，我早就知道了！杰克说这简直酷毙了。
Yeah, and then what's really cool is after that little moment of improv from both of them, they get back on script and finish the scene, which is, oh, just delicious. The line that got them back on script was Pete saying, and just so you know, there was no overlap. Mm-hmm. And then they were back as scripted. However, this does end with another improv when Andy
是的，然后最酷的是，在他们两个人的这个小即兴时刻之后，他们回到了剧本，完成了这场戏，哦，简直太精彩了。让他们回到剧本台词是皮特说的一句，顺便说一句，没有重叠期。嗯哼。然后他们就回到了剧本。然而，这最终以另一个即兴表演结束，当安迪
starts to sing the song, Bad Day, with different lyrics. We had a bad day. Different lyrics. Do, do, Day, with different lyrics. We had a bad day. Different lyrics. Do, do, do, do. Yes. From Steve Burgess, he said we had to get permission to change the lyrics. They were okay with using different lyrics
开始用不同的歌词唱起那首《糟糕的一天》（Bad Day）。我们度过了糟糕的一天。不同的歌词。嘟，嘟，天哪，唱着不同的歌词。我们度过了糟糕的一天。不同的歌词。嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟。是的。来自史蒂夫·伯吉斯的爆料，他说我们必须获得许可才能更改歌词。他们同意使用不同的歌词
and it cost $20,000. And he said, by the way, this wasn't scripted. So after Ed did it in the scene, they had to make sure they could get it cleared. Oh my gosh. After the scene, we see Andy and Toby, and Toby's like, hey, you cannot fire Pete. You can't fire someone just because you have a grudge. The same thing happened with Nellie. And Andy's like, no, no, no.
花费了2万美元。他说，顺便说一句，这不是剧本里写的。所以埃德在场景中即兴发挥后，他们必须确保能够获得版权清除。哦天哪。场景过后，我们看到安迪和托比，托比说，嘿，你不能解雇皮特。你不能仅仅因为个人积怨就解雇别人。内莉身上也发生过同样的事。安迪却说，不，不，不。
That was a professional grudge. This is a personal grudge. Yes. And then Toby shows Andy that Erin and Pete have disclosed their relationship. You know, they fill out that form and human resources. Andy is furious and crumples it up. Toby's like, that's not the original. So, you know, it's not a big deal. I just love that one detail. And then Andy walks away. Toby uncrumples it and is like, it is the original. Well, I looked this up in the script. As scripted, Andy was supposed to fold up the document and put it in his pocket and then kick Toby's chair and walk out. And Toby's last line was, it's not
那是一场职业积怨。这是一场个人积怨。是的。然后托比向安迪展示了艾琳和皮特已经公开了他们的关系。你知道的，他们在人力资源部填了那张表格。安迪怒火中烧，把表格揉成一团。托比说，这不是原件。所以，你知道的，这没什么大不了的。我太喜欢这个细节了。然后安迪走开了。托比把纸揉开说，这就是原件。好吧，我在剧本里查了查。按照剧本，安迪本该把文件叠好放进口袋，然后踢翻托比的椅子走出去。托比的最后一句台词是，这不是
the original. But instead, Ed crumpled it up and threw it at him. And he was like, it's not the original and kicked the trash can. And so Paul improvised. Un-crumpling it. Un-crumpling it and and saying it was the original. That is great. I love that. So fun. All right, are you ready for Pam to get to her interview?
原件。但相反，埃德把它揉成一团扔向了他。然后他说，这不是原件，还踢了垃圾桶。所以保罗即兴发挥。把纸重新揉展开。把它重新揉展开，然后说这就是原件。太棒了。我太喜欢了。太有趣了。好吧，你们准备好迎接帕姆去面试了吗？
I am, per the call sheets, this was the very first scene of this entire episode that was filmed. Yep, Monday morning. Monday morning, scene 24, first up on Monday. It was described like this, Interior Real Estate Company, Pam meets the Michael Scott of Real Estate, Mark.
我准备好了，根据通告单，这是整个剧集中拍摄的第一个场景。是的，星期一早上。星期一早上，第24场，周一首个拍摄场景。它是这样描述的：室内，房地产公司，帕姆遇到了房地产界的迈克尔·斯科特——马克。
And I saw on the call sheet that you and Bob had 6 a.m. call times, but the rest of us got to come in at one. Yep, this was a location. We did not build these offices, and I remembered that very clearly. We got ready on set and then we drove to this location in a series of
我在通告单上看到你和鲍勃的集合时间是早上6点，但我们其他人是1点才来。是的，这是一个外景地。我们没有搭建这些办公室，我对此记得非常清楚。我们在片场准备好，然后坐了一系列
vans. So Bob and I got to share a van ride over to the set. Listen, any time I got to share with Bob, I was just so tickled. So I remember that car ride. We got a lot of fan questions about what it was like for me to get to work with Bob. One from Natalie L. in Baltimore, Maryland, who just said, what was it like working with Bob Odenkirk? I laughed all morning. I only had him from 6 a.m. to 1 p.m.
面包车前往这个外景地。所以我和鲍勃共乘了一辆面包车去片场。听着，任何能和鲍勃共处的时光，我都觉得非常开心。所以我记得那趟车程。我们收到了很多粉丝的提问，问我和鲍勃合作是什么感觉。其中一位来自马里兰州巴尔的摩的娜塔莉·L.问，和鲍勃·奥登科克合作是什么体验？我一整个早上都在笑。我只有从早上6点到下午1点能跟他搭戏。
But oh my goodness, and one of my favorite moments that I couldn't get over and that I still can't get over when I watch it and made me break every time, I don't know how we got a usable take, was that dance that he does when he goes, the funk and bonch. Yeah. And he like, this is like awkwardly is raising the roof. I loved that moment so much.
但哦天哪，我最喜欢的片段之一，让我笑到不行、现在看还是笑到不行、每次都让我笑场不知怎么拍出可用镜头的，就是他那个舞蹈，就是那种放克风。对。他还有点尴尬地举起双手。我太喜欢那个瞬间了。
The minute he's on camera, I just started laughing. It starts with him in his office and he's playing the guitar, and he's saying, talking Chester Avenue, talking Triplex, talking Converting, hey, is that her? Yes. And you just have to imagine, this guy is making up these ridiculous songs all day.
他一上镜我就开始笑。一开始他在办公室里弹吉他，嘴里念叨着，切斯特大道，三层公寓，改建房，嘿，那是她吗？是的。你脑补一下，这家伙整天都在编这些荒唐的歌。
He must drive everyone crazy. Oh, yeah, Pam has a talking head, where she says, oh, my God, he's Michael Scott. And then he gives her a tour of the office. He kind of walks her through the bullpen, making all of the inappropriate jokes that Michael Scott would. And he says ridiculous things like Michael Scott would, like this. This is not an office so much as it's a rec room with a bunch of computers in it. Frankly, if I had my way, I'd toss the computers in the garbage.
他肯定把大家都逼疯了。哦，对，帕姆有个单采镜头，她说，哦，天哪，他就是迈克尔·斯科特。然后他带她参观办公室。他带着她走过开放式办公区，开着各种迈克尔·斯科特式的很不合时宜的玩笑。他还说出一些迈克尔·斯科特式的荒唐话，比如这样。与其说这是一间办公室，不如说是一个摆着一台台电脑的活动室。坦白说，如果我说了算，我就把电脑都扔进垃圾桶。
But unfortunately, we use them for practically everything we do. So, that ain't gonna happen. You might have noticed that only one person speaks back to him. Everybody in this bullpen were background performers, but they were very specifically chosen to try to paint the picture of an alternate Dunder Mifflin universe. For example, please note the snarling woman dressed in a turtleneck and pearls at 17 minutes and eight seconds. That is your doppelganger, Angela. There are people playing solitaire on their computers. I like Meredith. I noticed that. Mm-hmm. At 17 minutes and 24 seconds, Aunt Joan was their Phyllis.
但可惜的是，我们干什么几乎都离不开它们。所以，那是不可能的。你可能注意到了，只有一个人回应他。这个办公区里的所有人都是群演，但他们都是经过精心挑选的，旨在勾勒出一个平行世界的邓德米弗林。比如，请注意17分08秒时那个穿着高领毛衣、戴着珍珠项链的怒视镜头的女人。那是你的分身，安吉拉。有人在电脑上玩纸牌。我喜欢梅雷迪思。我注意到了。嗯-hmm。在17分24秒，琼阿姨就是他们的菲利斯。
She's wearing a purple shirt under her blazer. And then, as Mark comes around the corner, he's going to speak to someone and he's going to say, he didn't hear me. And that person says, I heard you. That was guest star Michael Weston. He was a very big shot actor at this time when he did this very short little cameo. He had been on House for two years and people noticed. We got a lot of fan mail asking, how did you get Michael Weston to do like this one little pop on your show, this little cameo. It's because Michael Weston was one of the actors who tested for Jim.
她西装外套里面穿着一件紫色衬衫。然后，当马克转过拐角时，他准备和一个人说话，他说，他没听见我。那个人说，我听见了。那是客串明星迈克尔·韦斯顿。他当时客串这个极短的小角色时，已经是一个很大牌的演员了。他在《豪斯医生》里演了两年，大家都注意到了。我们收到了很多粉丝来信问，你们是怎么请到迈克尔·斯科特的，哦不，迈克尔·韦斯顿在你们剧里客串这么一个小角色的。因为迈克尔·韦斯顿曾是为吉姆试镜的演员之一。
Oh, that's so cool that Greg did that. Yes. So he placed him as the man closest to reception because he would have been the Jim to their Pam. And Michael was so up for it. You know, Greg called and was like, Hey, do you want to come be in our alternate universe? Right. Very, very cool. Like you said, Greg, he files everything away. He does. Back at the Dunder Mifflin bullpen, Andy has waited for Aaron to leave and then he just lets the room have it. He's like, thanks a lot, you know, for letting Plop steal my girlfriend. And he's really hurt and he's getting upset and Darrell's like, Andy, you have a booger bubble forming?
哦，格雷格能这么做太酷了。对。所以他把他安排在离前台最近的人的位置，因为他本可以成为他们的吉姆。而且迈克尔非常乐意。你知道，格雷格打电话说，嘿，你想不想来我们的平行宇宙？对吧。非常非常酷。就像你说的，格雷格，他把所有事情都记在心里。确实。回到邓德米弗林办公区，安迪等埃伦离开后，就开始在房间里大发牢骚。他说，非常感谢你们，让普洛普抢走了我的女朋友。他真的很受伤，情绪很激动，而达里尔说，安迪，你鼻孔吹出鼻涕泡了？
And Andy's like, sorry, my whole life is a booger bubble. Y'all, this was on the call sheet. On Monday, they had a, and I quote, we will test the booger bubble at 10 a.m. Okay, I saw that as well, Angela. I love that they did a booger bubble test, but I never saw a booger bubble. Do you think that the test didn't happen
然后安迪说，抱歉，我整个人生就像个鼻涕泡。各位，通告单上居然有这个。周一的时候，他们有一场，我原话引述，我们将于上午10点测试鼻涕泡。好吧，安吉拉，我也看到了。我很高兴他们做了鼻涕泡测试，但我从没见过鼻涕泡。你觉得是不是测试没做成，
and so they just were like, he'll just indicate booger bubble because did you see one? I didn't see one. I didn't see one. I have to imagine that camera didn't really catch it. You know, when they did the camera test, they were like, oh, it doesn't really read. I zoomed in, I took a picture of Ed's nose,
所以他们就想，他就假装有鼻涕泡吧，因为你见到了吗？我没见到。我也没见到。我猜镜头大概没拍出来。你知道的，当他们做镜头测试时，他们会觉得，哦，这根本看不出来。我放大了，我拍了埃德的鼻子，
and I'm sorry. I saw no big booger bubble. So I think they tested it and it didn't work. I want to say that when they tested things like this, they would often grab our stand-in, Steven Sox, and they would have put a booger bubble on him at 10 a.m., and then he would have walked into the bullpen, and they would have put the camera up.
抱歉。我没看到什么大鼻涕泡。所以我觉得他们测试了，但没成功。我想说的是，当他们测试这种东西时，他们通常会抓住我们的替身演员史蒂芬·索克斯，在上午10点给他粘上一个鼻涕泡，然后他走进办公区，把摄像机架起来。
And then they would have said, no, it doesn't work. Yes. He did so many things like that. I really feel like at some point we need to get Stephen and his wife, Lori. They were our two stand-ins, because I want to hear stories of these crazy things that they were always having to do. I would love that. I would love to just say you guys list off 10 of the most crazy things you had to do behind the scenes. Agree. Okay, put that on the list.
然后他们会说，不行，这行不通。对。他做过很多类似的事情。我真的觉得我们有必要在某个时候请来史蒂芬和他的妻子洛瑞。他们是我们的两个替身演员，因为我想听听他们总是不得不做的这些疯狂事情的故事。我很乐意。我很乐意让你们列出你们在幕后不得不做的10件最疯狂的事情。同意。好吧，把这个记在单子上。
All right, now Pam's interview has moved into Mark's office. Before we step into his office, there was a line that cracked me up. I thought our writers did a brilliant job of bringing Michael Scott into this moment in the way that Michael Scott would do a comedy bit, but some part of it would be wrong. Okay. So Mark says, step this way for the Spanish Inquisition. And then he goes, kids in the hall. Yes. It's not kids in the hall. It's Monty Python. It's that hilarious Monty Python sketch. But I just love that little nod. It reminded me so much of Michael Scott.
好了，现在帕姆的面试移到了马克的办公室。在我们走进他的办公室之前，有一句台词把我逗乐了。我认为我们的编剧在把迈克尔·斯科特融入这一刻时做得非常出色，方式就像迈克尔·斯科特会做的一个喜剧包袱，但其中某些部分会搞错。好吧。所以马克说，请这边走，迎接西班牙宗教裁判所。然后他说，大厅里的孩子们。对。不是大厅里的孩子们。是巨蟒剧团。那个搞笑的巨蟒剧团小品。但我就是喜欢那个小小的致敬。它太让我想起迈克尔·斯科特了。
You know, Mark really likes her tiny resume. Yeah, you know what it says to him? She sticks around. She gets in one place and doesn't really go anywhere. Kind of stings when Pam hears it like that. Well, yeah. Angela, do we need to talk about some of the things on Mark's desk? There's so many good things. There's the clacky teeth. And clacky balls. And clacky balls. Clacky
你知道，马克真的很喜欢她那份简短的简历。对，你知道这对他意味着什么吗？她能坚持下来。她在一个地方待着，哪儿也不去。帕姆听到这样的话时，心里有点不是滋味。好吧，是的。安吉拉，我们要不要聊聊马克桌上的一些东西？有好多好东西。有那种会咔哒咔哒响的假牙。还有咔哒球。还有咔哒球。咔哒
teeth of course made me think of Michael Scott. He has one of those magic eight balls but it's the yellow one that looks like an emoji. Well Michael had a green one that had like a dollar symbol on it. Remember? We looked it up. Yep. And of course, he's got a jumbo set of clacky balls. And he also has like a, it looks like a version of some kind of bobblehead, but I can't see who it is. Could you make out who it was? I couldn't make out who it was. If anyone knows who that is, will you let us know?
牙齿当然让我想起了迈克尔·斯科特。他有一个那样的神奇8号球，但它是黄色的，看起来像个表情符号。好吧，迈克尔有一个绿色的，上面有一个美元符号。还记得吗？我们查过。是的。当然，他有一套超大的咔哒球。他还有一个，看起来像某种摇头娃娃的版本，但我看不清是谁。你能看出是谁吗？我看不清是谁。如果有人知道那是谁，能告诉我们吗？
There's something that Mark is going to do that Michael never did. And that is, will you let us know? There's something that Mark is gonna do that Michael never did, and that is play his guitar for her. Yeah. He's going to make up a song about her while reading her resume. I thought we should hear it. Oh, please. What if Bob Dylan was your boss?
马克要做一件迈克尔从未做过的事。那就是，能告诉我们吗？马克要做一件迈克尔从未做过的事，那就是为她弹吉他。对。他要在读她简历的同时为她编一首歌。我觉得我们应该听听。哦，拜托。如果鲍勃·迪伦是你的老板会怎样？
I'm gonna do Dylan. I'm gonna do Dylan. Pam Halpert is my name. I've been at Dunder Mifflin for seven years, eight years, eight years man. Got the Dunder Mifflin blues, got the Pam Halpert blues, got a prayer with the Bread Institute. You have children? Two children, yes. And you have art and painting? Kind of the same thing, kind of the same thing. Sometimes I repeat myself, but that's just being Pam. Well, I'm kind of cute and I'm, but I'm married, so. Leave that be.
我要模仿迪伦。我要模仿迪伦。帕姆·哈珀特是我的名字。我在邓德米弗林呆了七年，八年，八年啦，伙计。得了邓德米弗林忧郁症，得了帕姆·哈珀特忧郁症，跟面包研究所做个祈祷。你有孩子？两个孩子，是的。你还会艺术和画画？差不多是一回事，差不多是一回事。有时我重复自己，但那就是帕姆。嗯，我挺可爱的，而且，但我结婚了，所以。顺其自然吧。
But I'm married so leave that be. Angela, that whole thing was improvised. That was a nod to David Brent. When Bob and I met to practice our audition together, he did that. Then when we went in to do the test audition, he brought his guitar and we did that bit as part of the test process because David Brent. In the original GBC version.
但我结婚了，所以顺其自然吧。安吉拉，整段都是即兴发挥。那是对大卫·布伦特的致敬。当鲍勃和我见面一起练习试镜时，他就是这么做的。然后当我们进去进行测试试镜时，他带了吉他，我们把那段表演作为测试过程的一部分，因为大卫·布伦特。在最初的英国版里。
That's right. He would play the guitar. And so Bob did that. And I remember when we were talking about bringing Bob on to play Mark, I said, Greg, he's got to bring his guitar. That was like one of my favorite audition moments was getting to sit there and just react to Bob singing to me. It's so funny.
没错。他会弹吉他。所以鲍勃就那样做了。我记得当我们讨论请鲍勃来演马克时，我说，格雷格，他必须带上他的吉他。那是我最喜欢的试镜时刻之一，能坐在那里，对鲍勃对我唱歌做出反应。太搞笑了。
And he finds so many hills and valleys in the moment. I love when he was like, that's just B and Pam. Yeah. But then he's like, she's pretty cute, but she's married. And then to himself, he's like, leave it be. Yes. Yes. It's so good. But then he's like, she's pretty cute, but she's married. And then to himself, he's like, leave it be. Yes, yes. It's so good.
而且他在那一刻找到了那么多的起伏。我喜欢他唱“那就是帕姆和B”的时候。对。但随后他说，她挺可爱，但她已经结婚了。然后对自己说，顺其自然吧。是的。是的。太棒了。但随后他说，她挺可爱，但她已经结婚了。然后对自己说，顺其自然吧。是的，是的。太棒了。
Everybody, we spoke to Bob Odenkirk all about these scenes. His interview is going to run after we finish breaking down moving on part two. Please, please give it a listen. It's so fun. It's so fun. And he's so smart and interesting. We really hung on his every word.
各位，我们和鲍勃· O登柯克聊了所有关于这些场景的事。他的采访将在我们拆解完《向前看》第二部分后播出。请一定要听听看。太有趣了。太有趣了。而且他那么聪明，那么有趣。我们真的对他的每一句话都铭记于心。
We pretty much did. It's such a great interview. Well, this episode's gonna end with something we've never seen before, to be continued, dot, dot, dot. Once again, a huge thank you to Steve Burgess for those call sheets and behind the scenes details and to you all for writing in your questions and comments. They always give us such inspiration.
我们几乎是这样的。这是一次非常棒的采访。好吧，这一集将以我们从未见过的内容结束，未完待续，点，点，点。再次非常感谢史蒂芬·伯吉斯提供这些通告单和幕后细节，也感谢大家写信提出你们的问题和评论。他们总是给我们带来这样的灵感。
I really had a fun time rewatching this. I did too. Everyone join us next week for Moving On, part two. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins.
我重看这一集真的很开心。我也是。请大家下周加入我们，收看《向前看》第二部分。到时见。感谢收听办公室女士。办公室女士由Earwulf出品，詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。
Our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音频工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。